.
Moin Leute, ich war jetzt relativ früh, aber mir ist gestern Abend aufgefallen, da war es schon zu spät zum Streamsorn,
dass doch tatsächlich Season 5 rausgekommen ist von Battlefield 2042.
Ich habe das überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Schirm, also ich wusste prinzipiell, dass das rauskommt,
aber ich hatte keine Ahnung, dass das quasi schon, ja, gestern gewesen ist.
Letzte Runde Battlefield, genau. Ne, es kommt angeblich noch mittags, ja, heute ist Feiertag, oder?
Also zumindest in Hessen ist Feiertag.
Naja, ähm, also
man muss immer sagen
in einer Sache habe ich schon mal falsch gelegen.
Äh, das
Ja
Scam
Jawoll
Genau
Ja also in einer Sache habe ich schon mal wirklich falsch gelegen und das muss ich auch tatsächlich mal jetzt zugeben an der stelle
Da habe ich glaube ich sogar im letzten Video schon gekeckelt
Ähm ne
Also es gibt ernsthaft Leute, ja, die sind 38, sitzen beim Rechner und benutzen Keckel in ihrem normalen Satzbau
Also in einer Sache habe ich wirklich falsch gelegen und zwar das mit diesen 4 Schlusses
Ich habe ja prophezeit, nach dem verkackten Start machen die das Mindeste, was sie machen müssen
machen sie gar nichts mehr für das game gut man muss sagen so ein bisschen also
ganz unrecht hatte ich nicht das game weiß ich nicht ob das mittlerweile es
hat halbwegs release zustand vielleicht schon erreicht ja so man könnte so
langsamer in die beta gehen
ich meine die rotz maps sind immer noch nicht richtig überarbeitet nicht alle
zumindest weiß gar nicht wie es mit our class aussieht ist die our class
Überarbeitung jetzt eigentlich mit dabei.
Wir müssen erst mal ein bisschen in die Patch Notes gucken, bevor wir anfangen.
Ich habe vorhin schon mal
aufgemacht und die ganzen Pop-Ups weggedrückt,
weil das ist halt auch wieder geil, ne?
Du machst das Game zum ersten Mal auf, hast mal fünf Pop-Ups.
So, zeigt mal her, Battlefield Patch Notes, äh, BF News, müssen wir mal gucken.
News und Updates.
Briefing Entwicklungs...
Nee, Patch-Notes für Season 5.
Die gibt es, die gibt es, ich hab die letzten sogar gesehen.
Hier, Update 5, da ist es doch.
Stripes, moin, danke, für den Massive Sub.
Wer sich wundert, warum die Emotes heute so leise sind,
das liegt daran, weil ich die Gesamt-Lautstärke runterdrehen musste,
weil Battlefield irgendwie den Hang dazu hat, extrem laut zu sein mit meiner Default-
Sound-Lautstärke und ich weiß nicht genau warum.
Das ist nur eines der Merkwürdigkeiten, die dieses Game hat.
So...
Schauen wir mal.
Season 5, Battlefield 2042, deploys across all platforms.
Ja, gestern.
12 Uhr, UTC.
2 Stunden sind's, oder?
14 Uhr, ja.
Genau, 2 Stunden, CEST.
Ich bin mir heute nicht sicher, wie lange ich's aushalte.
Mal gucken.
Es hängt, es hängt drauf, es hängt, es hängt vom Game Up, wie lange ich es heute aushalte und der Titel ist Programm. Ich habe jetzt
Monate lang das Game nicht mehr angefasst. Leider sieht man es hier nicht, weil ich habe es vorhin schon gestartet.
Leider sieht man nicht, wann ich zuletzt gespielt habe. Es ist, aber ohne Scheiß, es ist Monate her. Also
prepare, prepare for PPGaim.
Ich meine, ich habe zwar den ein oder anderen Shooter gespielt in letzter Zeit, aber
Ob ich den Battlefield doch fast treffe, sei mal dahingestellt.
Mal gucken, wir werden wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Rush spielen, weil das der einzige Spielmodus ist, den ich in dem Spiel aushalte.
Okay, also was gibt's Neues? Neuer Content, zeigt mal.
Das Bild konnte man natürlich auch nicht höher auflösend machen.
Neue Map reclaimed.
Es gibt Mini-Granaten, Anti-Tank-Granaten.
und eine spring grenade wahrscheinlich so was was so so was was dann vom boden hoch springt
oder irgendwie so neue weapons kek w 46 ist das ist das die g 36 das die g 36 ohne dass
sie die die namensrechte noch an der g 36 haben was ist das für ein dateiname
Haha, Wordpress wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht wie Wordpress Sachen resized, StaticAsset1jpgAdaptCrop16zu9145withjpg, JustWordpressThings, ich vermute mal, dass das irgendwelche Wordpress Shit ist, ich weiß es aber nicht, ans Trinken erinnern, Dankeschön, Dankeschön.
Ja, ihr habt recht, ihr müsst mich ans Trinken erinnern. Ich hab extra neue Teetassee hingestellt.
Also, ne, mit Tee drinne, ja, sonst wär's ja irgendwie reichlich unsinnig.
Versuchen die das 2042 im Namen zu verstecken?
Ich glaube das Logo sah schon immer so aus auf diesen Bildern, aber ja, man könnte es vermuten.
Und wahrscheinlich wäre es nicht die schlechteste Idee, das zu verstecken im Namen, ja.
Wöp, dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay, also
New Store Items
Wait a minute
Die promoten für eine neue Season
dass es jetzt neue Microtransactions
gibt. Geil, okay, ich mein
der Shop ist halt auch lächerlich, da ist kaum was
drin, geschweige denn was, was ich haben will
Äh, New Experiences
Blablabla
Ja, das war ein Popup, was ich vorhin weggeklickt
hab
Full Year of Content
Okay, Moment, die sagen ja auch catch up, meint ihr das ist absichtlich so geschrieben, catch up on a full year of content, die schreiben nicht catch up on a year full of content, die schreiben full year, nicht year full of content, weil man muss sagen, das Jahr war nun wirklich nicht voller Content für das Spiel.
Erstens, haben sie viel zu spät angefangen mit ihren Content-Drops und zweitens, so wirklich viel kam ja auch gar nicht.
Es kam wirklich nur das, und das auch, wie ich das quasi so gesagt habe, mehr oder weniger, aber so das Mindeste, was sie versprochen haben,
plus das, was ich quasi auch in einem meiner allerersten Battlefield-Videos gesagt habe,
packt doch einfach den ganzen alten Mist noch mit rein, dass die Waffenleiste wenigstens nicht so leer aussieht
Und die sieht jetzt tatsächlich auch ein bisschen voller aus.
Es gibt neue Skins und Gedöns.
Oh! Squad-Management!
Wait a minute! Kann man etwa das Squad jetzt wechseln?
Was ist da los? Ernsthaft?
Legacy-Feature!
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe, dass man das Squad wechseln kann.
kann. Man kann das ernsthaft, man kann jetzt das Squad wechseln. Alter, wer braucht eigentlich
solche Legacy Features? Class System is back. Gut, das war es ja eigentlich. Vorher schon mehr
mehr oder weniger oder nicht?
Oder war das das letzte Mal nur groß angekündigt?
Also ich mein das Class Feature ist genauso wenig back
ja gut, ein bisschen, eigentlich hat sich nicht wirklich viel geändert
wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
haben sie sich einfach hingesetzt, haben die Specialists genommen
haben eigentlich die Specialists mehr oder weniger so gelassen
nur, dass sie es etwas restriktiver gemacht haben
wer jetzt was ausrüsten kann
kann und die, also die ganzen Specialist waren ja eh schon grob immer in der Klasse zugeordnet,
nur dass es halt bisher keine Auswirkungen hatte.
Jetzt gibt es irgendwie eine Klassenperk und wir gucken uns gleich die Patchnotes an.
Es gibt irgendwie eine Klassenperk und halt bisschen restriktiver was man picken kann.
Lass uns mal kurz die Patchnotes angucken.
Das ist bestimmt die G36, Keg W 46, Keg W 56, äh äh 56 alter, 46, es ist auch immer total
merkwürdig ne, immer wenn man die Sachen auf Englisch sagt, das ist ja 46 und wir sagen
46, warum sagen wir das eigentlich verkehrt herum?
Relative Life Improvements, World Weapons, Attachments. Aha, ja endlich sehr nice. Das
muss man uns gleich mal angucken. Da bin ich gespannt drauf. Attachments für World Weapons,
das ist cool. Bisher waren gerade die Battlefield 3 Weapons, die sie reingepatcht haben in das
Game, halt, ja, genau so ohne, ohne dass du großartig was anlocken konntest oder großartig
was dran machen konntest. Das ist nicht schlecht. Also es gibt eine neue Map, Reclaimed, das
gucken wir uns dann gleich an. Neue Weapons, eine Desert Eagle, sowas in der Richtung zumindest.
Keg W-46
Also ja das ist ne... Leute das ist ne G36 oder?
Das sieht original aus wie ne G... Die haben bestimmt einfach nur die Heckler & Koch Waffenrechte nicht mehr da dran
Die Namensrechte, nicht Waffen, NAMENSRECHTE an den Waffen
Sooo
360 No Scope
Granaten
Ah!
Der Klassiker
New Battle Pass, ja gut, okay.
Vault Weapons Attack, ja das ist, das ist sehr nice, das gefällt mir gut.
Das gefällt mir gut, das müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Ah gut, Skins juckt mich nicht.
Vehicle Loadouts, okay, fahre ich sehr wenig dank der Fahrphysik in dem Spiel.
in dem spiel
vor 20
squat management im problem so langsam
squat functionality wird im problem
man kann wirklich wieder squads auswählen
endlich alter ok so langsam aber sicher
so langsam aber sicher würde ich sagen
Wir nähern uns einem spiel was man battlefield nennen kann
Wo man jetzt langsam mal dran denken könnte es vielleicht mal in so ein public playtest zu packen
Oder vielleicht dass man vielleicht könnte man das spiel ende des jahres releasen wenn der wenn der playtest jetzt gut läuft
Ich weiß kake way das game schon eineinhalb jahren draus aber ich würde sagen ich würde sagen so in diesem in diesem zustand
Könnte man das jetzt könnte man das jetzt langsam aber sicher mal ans releasen denken
Great, enjoy, easy navigation.
Äh, was?
Damage unit?
Damage point, was?
Äh, ach, wieviel Damage ich an dem, hmmm, ich bin grad am überlegen, ob das jetzt was
Gutes oder was schlechtes sollte man das einblenden oder nicht was denkt ihr
also ich frage mich ich frage mich gerade in dem spiel was mir die damage nummern so großartig bringen weil
Weil die time to kill ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig hoch und man sieht ja auch wenn er umkippt
Aber vielleicht macht das manchmal doch sinn
Mal gucken
We aim to the target
Was?
Okay das ist eine Sache die finde ich bescheuert
Also nicht die Änderung
Nicht die Änderung an sich dass man
Accuracy und Spray und sowas
ein bisschen anpasst aber
Warum um alles in der Welt nur Assault Rifles
Warum, in Anführungsstrichen, nerft man einfach eine komplette Waffenkategorie und lässt den Rest so?
Gut, die Frage ist, ist das überhaupt eine Nerf? Es sei denn, die killen jetzt halt schneller, wenn man sich ein bisschen kontrolliert mit Burstfire und...
Ich mein, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so übel.
Das können wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich find sowas fragwürdig, wenn man sowas nur komplett auf eine Waffenkategorie drauf klatscht.
Naja, okay. Schauen wir mal.
New Unlock... äh...
Requirement...
Ist mir egal.
Spiel ich eh nicht. Kamera Sprint Movement.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Let's go. Ach ja.
Ähm, Chat.
Das FPS Overlay in Battlefield war kacke, oder?
In Battlefield 2042.
Wisst ihr was, wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Game Bar oder wie das Ding hieß.
Ich hab das legit, ernsthaft.
What the fuck, Alter.
Was sehe ich hier?
Performance Overlay, ja das finde ich gut.
Ach ihr seht das nicht?
Ihr seht das nicht?
Obwohl ich den kompletten Bildschirm capture, das ist interesting.
Das ist interessant, okay, das ist interessant, ich hab gedacht Display Capture ist Display
Capture.
Interessant.
Na gut, ich mein, dann müssen wir den
Ingame hier playen.
Und dann müssen wir Ingame das
Performance overlayen. Oder
wir installieren schnell Afterburner.
Weil ich will wissen, wie gut die Performance ist.
Weil ich mein, mein neuer Rechner sollte das Game
ja easy as fuck handeln.
Das sollte eigentlich permanent mit
keine Ahnung, 300 FPS flutschen
und flitzen.
Oh ne, nicht wieder der Scheiß!
Nicht wieder der Scheiß, wie das letzte Mal.
Ich raste aus, Alter.
Nicht wieder der Kram, dass ich es nicht starten kann richtig.
Come on.
Oh ne, ne, ich glaube es startet.
Oh ne, ne ich glaube es startet
Oder?
Ja
Oh haben wir aber noch mal Glück gehabt
Da haben wir aber noch mal Glück gehabt
Sollte, sollte es nicht
Sollte es nicht jetzt eigentlich einen Sound geben?
Oder ist es
Sound?
Pause Champ?
Ich starte mal kurz in den Game. Wir müssen mal die Sound-Lautstärke checken.
Ich glaube, hat das Game komische Dinge rumgestellt, hier Display?
Ne, das sieht eigentlich okay aus.
Vielleicht muss ich die Lautstärke doch wieder hochstellen.
Battlefield-Sound-Settings resetten sich bei mir auch öfters mal.
Aber immer noch besser wie Modern Warfare 2019,
2019 was immer den sound auf anschlag gedingst hat am anfang immer auf den auf anschlag gestellt hat
Auf okay ist doch ein bisschen sehr leise ich ja ist ein bisschen sehr leise wenn das bestimmt neue soundquelle dafür ja ich weiß nicht was
da los ist
okay
Wartet mal
Ja es ist natürlich wichtig dass wenn man solo spielt dass man 20 sekunden warten muss bis das ganze losgeht
Ich frage mich eigentlich, wie wir das früher in älteren Spielen gepackt haben, von einem Game ins andere direkt zu skippen, immer ohne zwei Minuten Pause dazwischen, da müssen wir einen Halben-März-Infarkt bekommen haben.
So, lass mal Lautstärke testen.
Viel zu leise. LOL! Viel zu leise.
Das kann man hier drauf machen, ne?
Ja, okay, dann lass endlich nix.
Schon besser, bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob es gut ist.
Bisschen lauter können wir, glaube ich, noch machen.
Ich glaube, so ist ganz gut.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz brauchbar, oder? So?
Lass mal, lass mal kurz... Ja, ja, ja, ich glaube, das ist gut. Das ist gut.
Exzellent, exzellent.
So, wie ist das?
Draw...
Ne, Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS...
Eins.
Genau.
Ich erinnere mich wieder, die Anzeige von FPS war in dem Spiel so unglaublich beschissen,
da habe ich immer nicht gecheckt, was es sein soll.
Gibt es...
Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS, Method...
Äh...
Eins?
Zwei
Drei
Okay da mache ich wirklich einen Unterschied
Ich hätte gerne ordentliche FPS Anzeige
Ähm und ich hätte auch gerne eine FPS Anzeige
die ihr seht
Ähm
Wow, die zieht aber ganz schön hoch.
Ja, ja, ihr seht das, aber die Anzeige ist halt unsinnig.
Weil ich meine, was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, die Anzeige da oben?
410 durch 2,6. Soll ich jetzt Quick-Maps im Kopf machen oder wie?
Was das, wieviel FPS ich hab?
Ne, ne, es sind nicht 350.
Es sind 350 durch 2,6 oder sowas.
Also irgendwie 160 oder sowas.
Ja, wir installieren schnell einen Afterburner.
Ach, wurscht. Komm.
Solange es nicht ruckelt,
solange es nicht ruckelt, soll mir das Recht sein. Easy.
Ach, das erste ist FPS
und das zweite ist die
Dauer pro Frame, oder wie die es rendern braucht.
Ah, das ist okay. Ich hatte nur im Hinterkopf,
dass es total beschissen ist, die Anzeige.
So, wir müssen jetzt erstmal zum Einspielen, weil wie gesagt,
preparet euch für Hartes PP-Geheim.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal zum Einspielen und wenn wir Glück haben, kommt jetzt gleich die neue Map.
Zeigt mal her, was gibt's im Battle Pass?
Es gibt ein Skin.
Nein, das waren wir nicht.
So, ähm, so, was haben wir denn hier?
Hä? Ist das nicht das gleiche?
Ach dieses Ding!
Who cares man?
Das ist so ein Ding, das verstehe ich in vielen modernen Games nicht.
Diese Sachen mit Charms, Handschuhe, Sprays, Aufdruck.
Es gibt so ganz viel Kleinscheiß.
Den siehst du beim Spielen gar nicht richtig.
Keine Ahnung warum es das überhaupt gibt.
Ja doch ich weiß warum es das gibt.
warum es das gibt. Okay, seriously, ich weiß warum es das gibt, dass man den Battle Pass,
die Tiers gefüllt bekommt, weil ich meine, wie wollen die ernsthaft 100 Level mit nicht
vorhandenem Inhalt irgendwie füllen? Das ist nur Sinn, das ist, dass du quasi sagen
kannst, wir haben 100 Battle Pass Level, aber in Wirklichkeit sind es halt nur 7, 8 gescheite
Sachen. Warum kosten bei CS-Skins 100 Euro? Weil die Leute halt gerne CS-Skins handeln
und dafür das Geld ausgeben.
CS-Skins sind halt so'n Ding.
Da geht's ja auch nicht um den Ingame-Store oder so, wo das kostet.
Sondern halt, was die Leute bereit sind dafür, über irgendwelche Trading-Seiten auszugeben.
Klar, letztendlich hängt's auch ein bisschen mit dem Ingame-Store zusammen,
also was Schlüsselkosten, falls das noch dieses Schlüsselsystem überhaupt ist.
Ich glaub, ich hab die Map ewig nicht mal...
What the hell?
...ewig nicht mal auf Attacker gespielt.
Ich habe es euch gesagt, Leute, es ist nicht so, ich habe es, ich habe es, ich habe es euch
Es wird PP geaimt, as fuck!
Oh Mist!
Ich hab gerade noch nachgeladen!
Das wird was, ich sag's euch!
Das wird... Oh Mist, ich hätte bei dem anderen rein spawnen sollen!
Wow!
Okay, okay, okay, wo seid ihr, ihr kleinen Pepegas?
Keck W46, die brauche ich, vielleicht habe ich Glück, guck mal, da kommt ein Medic,
kommt ein Medic, Medic, Pogu, Pogu-Medic.
Aufs Dach?
Also wie gesagt Leute, ich hab'n Monat...
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Ich hab'n Monat nicht gespielt.
Der ist bestimmt noch da.
Oh, fuck!
Ich dachte genau, das Messer trifft.
Was? Disarmed?
Anzeige ist raus. Warum disarmen die das?
Oh Oh
Oh oh oh oh oh neiiin
Von der Seite weggerotzt
Ein Monat ist zu viel
Ich weiß leider grad nicht, Chat geh auf was sich das bezieht
Mein Boomerbrain kann nicht so viel gleichzeitig zu prozessen
Ihr müsst da nachsichtig sein.
Okay, die Assault-Rifles schießen sich jetzt wirklich schwieriger.
Muss man sagen.
Das ist tatsächlich schwieriger zu schießen jetzt.
Du musst so tappen.
Guck, wenn du tappst, ist es okay.
Okay, okay.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde,
weil die anderen Waffen halt bis jetzt nicht genervt sind.
Es ist nur die Assault Rifles, ja.
Das ist es halt.
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum er nur die Assault Rifles gemacht hat.
Und guck mal, wir haben jetzt einen Smoke Launcher.
Pass mal auf.
Den rette ich jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, mach ich nicht.
Ist der Behinderte Doppelsprint raus?
Ähm...
Du meinst, das da?
Ne, der ist immer noch da.
Okay, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie die Map überhaupt aufgebaut ist, wenn ich
ehrlich bin.
Konnte man...
Nice!
Easy Snipe!
Konnte man da nicht hinten irgendwie sich durch, durch, durch stelzen so?
Doch, ne?
Man konnte...
Oder wir gehen oben drauf.
Da bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher.
Nein?
So, aber da oben sind ja meistens keine Gegner, aber man konnte, man konnte doch hier hinten
glaube ich recht gut.
Wie ist das Schiff hier eigentlich hingekommen?
Gibt es da schon Theorien zu?
Hat sich ja irgendwie mal einer die Battlefield-Lore angeguckt.
Pass auf, pass auf, lege Hänne!
Oh von hinten kommt gleich was, Achtung!
Wie, kommt da nix?
Was ist das?
Wie? Da kommt nix? Oh, jetzt aber!
Oh Gott, Alter! Keckel! Aber meine Legehenne war erfolgreich!
Ja natürlich müssen wir das, ich habe monatelang nicht gespielt.
Kann man da drauf?
Haben die noch ein bisschen mehr Container hingestellt?
Okay, das über Range kannst du knicken.
Oh, geht das nicht auf?
Jetzt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher von wo.
Und unsicher, wo hier was geht.
Aha, nice.
Taucht man eigentlich auf der Map auf, wenn man nicht mit Silencer schießt, oder ist das irgendwie besonders in dem Game? Ich kann mich da nicht mal dran erinnern.
Chatge.
Ach fuck, hier geht's ja gar nicht weiter.
Ich bin, ich bin übelst planlos. Ich weiß nicht, wo's lang geht.
So, okay. Stell's nochmal hier lang.
Ja klar, das überlebt er!
Shit!
Wrecked!
Äh, what?
Was?
kann man da hoch?
nope
ey ich kenn nichts mehr
ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr wo hier
ich weiß auf der Map waren hier an der Stelle
richtig richtig gute Tricks
wie man sich rein mit dem Grappling-Hook, wo man eine gute Position sich suchen konnte.
Ich muss aufpassen, kommen die nicht eigentlich von hinten?
Moment, war das ein Wurfmesser?
Ne neue neue Map hab ich nicht
Man muss wirklich tappen man muss richtig krass tappen dass es dass es funktioniert leute
So jetzt gehen wir hinten rum wir gehen hinten rum
Gachi Bass Style
In der Hoffnung guckt keiner
Ne ne Moment Moment kann man da rauf
ich hab was gehört
wusste ich doch, dass ich was gehört hab, lul
okay das ist ein Game, in dem man anscheinend mittlerweile halbwegs
gescheit was hören kann
beziehungsweise orten kann
von wo? von wo? von wo?
naja das war nicht auf mich
so geht dieses bunny gehopper eigentlich noch?
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich 64 Spieler?
Oder ist das 100? Das ist 64, ne?
Rush war schon immer 64.
Okay, man muss richtig krass happen, dass man über Range was trifft.
Ich hab nen Granate, ich hab nen Granatwerfer-Dude gehört.
Okay, mit, mit Tappen geht es.
Mit Tappen geht es, tatsächlich.
Boah, noch mal Glück gehabt.
Ich versteck mich mal hier hinten.
Oh ich hab keine Schuss mehr, Mist, das brauch ich hier, gib her, Muni, Muni, Muni, Muni
Äh, ne auf die Range, Suck, Suck das
Kannste aber vollknicken
Oh Gott, hab ich den PP geaimt, habt ihr das gesehen?
Aber immerhin 24, ey!
All that fuck, aber geht trotzdem noch was rein.
Spawnen, please.
Ja, auf.
Bam, erste Runde, easy win.
Pass auf, das Game sagt mir jetzt in der, wie das so, die planten ja so total unsinnige
Statistiken ein am Ende der Runde so. So du weißt was ich, du hast 20 Kills gemacht und dann planten sie ein
Ein Revive oder sowas
Okay für mich für nix eingeplantet. Was, was, was krieg ich für ein
Damage Dealt? Okay, die wollen nicht Kills. Nein, nein, 15 Kills sind selbstverständlich besser als 20 Damage Dealt. Okay, na dann
Wieder am Loops bashen, naja
Frage ist, aktuell eher, wer hier der Noob ist.
Boah Leute, ich muss kurz mal rüber die Fernbedienung für die Klimaanlage holen, hier ist übertrieben heiß.
Leute, hier ist gerade knapp 28 Grad drinne.
Mein Rechner ist aber auch hier.
Der ist grad voll am eskalieren.
Also der Rechner ist wirklich eine Heizung, wenn ich die Hand dort drüber halte gerade.
Also der Radiator von der Wasserkühlung, da wo die Lüfter bei der Wasserkühlung quasi
durchpusten.
Das hier ist wirklich wie ein Heizlüfter im Bad gerade, was da rauskommt.
RTX 4090 Heizung, also die CPU haut halt richtig rein und die Grafikkarte vor allem.
Aber die Grafikkarte geht ja nicht über die Wasserkühlung.
Aber gut, die Lüfter ziehen halt auch Sachen von der Grafikkarte raus.
Das ist halt so eine Mischung, CPU und Grafikkarte.
Also es kommt richtig warme Luft hinten raus und halt oben.
Oben ist halt der 140 mm Radiator mit so drei Lüftern drin.
Also Wasserkühlung für die CPU.
Und die Grafikkarte selbst hat ja auch drei fette Kühler drauf.
Rusch! Warum braucht Rusch? 40 Sekunden zum Suchen. Okay, wir schauen uns mal was anderes
an. Haben wir was unlockt? Battle Pass. Wann unlockt man denn eigentlich die Keg W46? Wann
gibts denn die? Hier, Keg W46, die gibt es, Battle Pass 28. Hmm, da brauche ich aber eine
ganze Weile für. Habe ich nicht noch XP-Boost und sowas? Doch, habe ich. Es ist immer Leute,
Leute! Rush! Neue Map! BÄM!
Alle spielen die neue Kataoni-Playlist, aber die gibt's nicht für Rush, oder?
Die gibt's nur für Breakthrough und Conquest.
Oder, oder, oder, Chetke?
Ich glaube schon.
Meinst du, ich soll den Battle Pass Pay2Win auf Level 28?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das können sie vergessen.
vergessen ich pay to win in dem game was heißt pay to win es ist ja nicht pay to win nicht so wirklich zumindest
ich pay in dem game gar nix ich habe dem spiel so krasse vorschusslorbeeren gegeben und
Ja ne ne ne ich habe sogar promotion okay paid promotion aber ich habe sogar promotion gemacht auf youtube für das game
Die waren übrigens nicht so happy mit meiner Promotion, sie haben es zwar nie so direkt
gesagt, aber ich glaube die fanden es nicht gut, dass ich zwei Promotion Videos hochgeladen
habe und dann ein Video, ich weiß nicht mehr wie es hieß, Battlefield 2042 eine Schande
für alle Fans oder irgendwie sowas, ich weiß nicht mehr wie ich das Video genannt habe,
das hat ihnen zumindest nicht gefallen, dass ich zwischen zwei Promotion, also zwischen
den den ersten zwei und im dritten promotion video ein video hochgeladen habe wo ich halt einfach mal gesagt habe dass ich das game
in einem nicht release würdigen kack zustand finde und auch viele sachen bescheuert gemacht sind und das das das
mochten die glaube ich nicht so
seitdem hat man übrigens auch mich nichts mehr angefragt eingeladen oder sonst was also
ich bin dead gift für battlefield aber das ist auch okay stört mich nicht
Mir ist es eh lieber.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Oh, die Assault Rifles
auf Range, krasser Scheiß.
Boah, das ist tatsächlich nicht so ohne jetzt.
Das ist echt nicht so ohne jetzt
damit zu treffen.
Es liegt erstens an prepare for
Pepega-Aim, aber es liegt
auch, dass das Handling der Dinger wirklich schwerer
geworden ist.
Das muss man, muss man sagen. Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, der erste Schuss allein schon. Seht ihr, wie der kickt?
Die ersten zwei Schüsse. Das ist echt gar nicht so, gar nicht so einfach.
Erinnert mich an eine Battlefield 1 Karte.
Wo, wo geht hier was überhaupt gerade?
Beide Objekte sind zerstört.
Jetzt geht es in die nächste Sektion.
Wir sind klar.
Geht in die nächste Sektion.
Die hat ein bisschen, wirklich ein bisschen was von Zavod, Zavod gekommrits.
Au!
Okay, neue Map, ist für alle neu, ist die ersten Runden immer übelst chaotisch, weil keiner weiß was er macht.
was er macht
Oh nice, nicer Spawn, nicer Spawn
Dach, Dach, Dach
Nice, sehr gut, sehr gut
Dachstelz, Beste
Rooftop Stelz
Alter, das ist wirklich...
Ey!
Das ist wirklich nicht so easy mit den Dingern zu treffen jetzt
No Joke Keckel
Leute
Echt, echt nicht so einfach
Das ist, das ist ne blöde Idee hier rumzurennen, oder?
Ist das, ist das ne gute oder ne schlechte Idee?
Ich glaube, ich glaube das ist ne schlechte Idee
Oder ist die Six Hand und die rechnen nicht damit
alles alles möglich
jetzt machen sie das nachher
Achtung Achtung Achtung
Nice
Pfeifer
Oh oh oh
Von wo? Von wo?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
von wo?
Leute ich hab ein Problem, ich weiß echt nicht wo.
Wo? Wo? Wo? Ach, unter mir!
Lul.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ok.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von wo, aber ich bin hier auch total
exposed aufm Dach.
Sehr agil, ja. Ja.
Daily Scrum war hier einfach aufm Dach gerade.
Ich geh wieder aufs Dach.
Man muss das, man muss das ausnutzen, wenn man den Typ spielt.
Okay, wir sollten... Oh shit!
Ich muss mal kurz hier liegen bleiben.
Es war klar, dass der schneidet.
Okay, was machen wir denn jetzt? Ich habe einen Smoke-Launcher dabei. Ach, wir haben es schon!
Ach, wir haben... Easy!
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Ich dachte, wir beißen uns hier gerade die Zähne aus an einem Ein-M-Kommen, aber anscheinend nicht.
Ich muss vertikal skalieren? Ne.
Leute, also, seriously, cringe, also massive cringe.
Wer überhaupt noch horizontal oder vertikal skaliert?
Ich habe schon oft hier im Stream gesagt,
gesagt richtig richtig agilen modernen
hippen leute die skalieren nur noch
diagonal weil dann hast du alles auf
einmal
da war hinter dem baum steht doch einer
what the fuck
ach der war hinter 30 milliarden
schildern
Wunderbar, warum ich den... Oh, was ist hier?
Gott, warum ich den nicht hätte?
Nee, nein, machste nix.
Oh, oh, oh, ganz schlechte Idee, ganz schlechte Idee.
Ich, ich verpiss mich hier immer wieder.
Kann man hier drüber?
Da ist irgendein Schneiper, Dude. Du triffst mich nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, du triffst mich nicht. Easy.
Easy.
Dodged.
Easy dodge.
Vierdimensional skalieren?
Ne, da kommst du ja wieder da an, wo du aufgehört hast.
Okay, ich renn einfach mal vor.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, wo irgendwelche Gegner sind.
Aber wir haben das M-Com.
Nice.
Easy win.
Null gecheckt, die Map beim ersten Mal spielen.
Aber, wir wurden gecarried von Mary-Chan.
Ah ja ja.
Mary-Chan.
Nee, oder?
Ach nee, Chain.
Ah.
Mary-Chan wär mir lieber gewesen.
Ich muss mal kurz Chat gelesen.
Während das, während das...
Ja, lass mal gucken, was das Game der Meinung ist.
Elf Assault Rifle Kills.
Die sind nur 5. Squad. Ist ja mies.
So, Chat-Gear.
War das die Battlefield-4-Map? Savot. Ja, das war die Battlefield-4-Map.
Das war diese Fabrik-Map.
Ich glaube Savot heißt sogar...
Heißt sogar Fabrik, nicht Savit. Savot.
Institution. Ich dachte es heißt Fabrik.
Ach, das ist slowenisch. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Russisch. Anlage heißt das. Okay, Anlage oder Fabrik.
Das sind zu viel, zu wenig Container. Leute, ist euch aufgefallen? Auf der neuen Map waren kaum
Container. Es waren dafür Zugwagons an jeder Ecke. Es waren weniger Container.
JustMX, naja, ich auch, aber eher aus dem Grund, weil ich halt einfach mal Bock hätte
wieder ordentlich Battlefield zu spielen.
Oh, was habe ich unlockt?
Extended Mag, oh, und ein LWG-Crip, Collection, zeig mal kurz her, lass uns das mal kurz attachen.
Extended, okay der Reload Speed ist noch langsamer.
Okay das ist natürlich ernsthaft sehr pp-ger, weil der Reload Speed ist jetzt schon ziemlich
lahm.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
wow
bipod braucht keiner
äh
ok
wieder reclaimed
nochmal die neue map
da will ich mich ja mal nicht beschweren
wenn wir rush jetzt öfters mal die neue map spielen dürfen
bis man halbwegs durchblickt
sehr nice
poke u
so was haben wir denn sonst noch
das sind so die
Leute, wenn die Underbarrels überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen, dann kann man die doch
auch einfach mal dran machen.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen, ach das ist ein Single-Shot-Shotgun und das ist
Ne
Was machen wir hiermit?
I'm moving
Ne das ist gut ich move hier eigentlich fast immer
Barrel
Suppressor
Minimap Stealth
Ok mal gucken
Ich will
Mal schauen ob das was taugt
Oh, es geht schon los!
Wait a minute...
Moment, die haben schon... Ja, geil!
Okay, wir machen jetzt mal die Shotgun dran.
Habt ihr einen Plan, was ich für ein
Shotgun drücken muss, dass ich den...
dass ich den Shot... dass ich das... das...
ausrüsten kann?
Also...
Was muss ich drücken
überhaupt dafür?
x
Oh, oh, oh! Pass auf, der pusht mich!
Shit, da war einer von der Seite.
Sonst hätte ich den pre-fired, er wäre dead gewesen.
Richtig im Sarg hergelegen.
So, ok, mal gucken, ob wir mit dem Silencer ein bisschen Flank-Action machen können.
Ich, ich, ich...
Shit.
Ey, da steht man, also das ist eine blöde Seite, da steht man zu offen, das ist nix.
Das ist nix, nixke ist das.
Ah, ist okay, okay, okay.
Da hinten sind viele, Achtung, Granate.
Wait a minute, ich habe dieses verfickte, ich habe das Wurfmesser.
Okay, das Wurfmesser ist nicht so geil hier jetzt.
Ich muss weg, ich muss weg, ich muss weg, ich muss weg.
Shit.
Weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
MonkaS, MonkaS, MonkaS.
Okay.
Da kommen jetzt welche, Achtung.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob er da rauskommt oder da raus.
Die müssen doch hier raus kommen jetzt!
Komm raus!
Alter, dudes, wo seid ihr?
Okay, die haben keinen Bock.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf, was wir jetzt machen.
Wir machen jetzt exzellent Pfeilverteilen.
Oh ne, wollen wir nicht.
Es hätte klappen können.
Manchmal ist es so,
dass man sich so ein bisschen
auf den Weg bringt.
Und dann ist es so,
Manchmal muss man es einfach probieren, gerade als Defender, wo man keine Ticket-Probleme hat.
Okay.
Okay, wir sollten auf jeden Fall hier hinten die abfangen.
Ah! Ich kann nicht schießen!
Weil die Nachlade-Animation ist ja ewig lang bei dem Ding.
Pass mal auf, wie lang die ist.
Ah, shit.
Die ist mega lang.
Du denkst, die ist fertig und in Wirklichkeit läuft die noch zwei Sekunden länger.
Guck mal, guck mal, man denkt jetzt ist sie fertig, aber jetzt ist sie fertig.
Ich glaube ich bin gar nicht am Gegner gestorben, sondern an...
Nee, nee, nee, bin ich nicht. Ich bin in der Zone.
Request revive!
Guck mal!
Ich bin am Gegner gestorben!
WEST REVIVE
Komm mal! Medic! Medic!
Ihr zwei da oben!
Medic!
Help!
Ja! Ja! Ja! Ja!
Ja! Oh nice!
Die Engagement-Area links.
Ich bin weg!
Schau' dir die Hände an, zurück zum Feind.
Ich bin weg von deiner Position!
Niemals!
Ich bin weg!
Das hat sich, das hat sich nicht gelohnt.
Ich bin deadge.
Ich bin einfach komplett deadge.
Nein, ich bin nicht deadge.
Habt ihr gedacht, ich komm Paxi raus?
Ich nicht.
Hätt ich selbst nicht gedacht.
Pass mal auf, der wird gewurfmessert jetzt.
Was ein Gekämpe hier an der Ecke, Mensch!
Smoke?
Die pushen jetzt durch während Smoke ist, zumindest würde ich das an ihrer Stelle machen.
Sag ich doch!
Oh!
Squad-Kollege hockt mit Sniper in der Base, Leute, das ist doch, das ist doch Standard!
Das ist doch, das ist doch normal!
Dass die mit Sniper in der Base hocken.
Okay, Dauerfeuer, das muss ich mir abgewöhnen.
Dauerfeuer ist echt nicht wirklich praktikabel.
Da liegt einer.
Das ist echt blöd.
Also, die Assault Rifles...
Was machen wir denn jetzt mal?
Ich hab keinen Bock jetzt die ganze Zeit da rumzustehen in der Eck.
Gehen wir mal. Gehen wir mal hier gucken.
Gehen wir uns mal hier ein bisschen lang stelzen und schauen was abgeht.
Vielleicht kriegen wir was von der Seite weg.
Sache ist nur die... Oh! Lege Hänne! Lege Hänne!
Lege Hände!
Oder... Disable!
Ja! Easy!
Easy!
Da kannst du mich auch ruhig snipen, ist mir egal.
Snipe mich ruhig beim Defenden.
Solange du mich erst snipest, wenn ich
defused habe, ist alles okay.
Was macht denn der Gang so?
Hier wird bestimmt klare Glasfaser verlegt.
Oh oh oh, was ist das?
Win!
Giga Chat Objective Players, so sieht es aus.
Guck mal, ich bin erster, weil ich Objectives das Abend habe.
...
SweetPotatoWedge schreibt, wir haben einen Brief bekommen, wir kriegen kostenlos Glasfaser in den Keller.
Das ist nice, da wäre ich auch sofort dabei.
Wenn wir kostenlos Glasfaser kriegen. Ich wäre sogar dabei,
wenn wir nicht kostenlos Glasfaser kriegen. Ich wäre sogar bei Paid-Glasfaser dabei.
Hauptsache Glasfaser. Und dann, wisst ihr was? Dann Celebration weg von Vodafone.
Ja, wir wollen alle Glasfaser.
Na gut, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Die Oma um die Ecke, die will wahrscheinlich kein Glasfaser, weil die dann sagt so nach dem Motto
Ach, ich benutze das Internet doch so selten und ich bin eh alt und ich bin eh langsam.
Da brauche ich doch gar nicht so schnelles Internet.
Ne, ne, dafür lass, dafür sollen die nicht bei mir die Straße aufbuddeln, dann will ich lieber nix.
Das ist das, was sie nur nach 15 Oma oder nur nach 15 Opa in Deutschland sagt, wenn es um Glasfaserausbau geht, was irgendwie auch nur ein Millimeter seines, seines Grundstücks tangiert.
Briefe schreiben, Brieftauben schicken.
Mal gucken, was wir...
Die Map ist so mal Top, mal Flop.
Ich wollte übrigens noch andere Attachments mal checken.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Also haben wir sonst noch irgendwie...
Ne, da gibt's sonst nix mehr.
Was haben wir als Lauf?
Auch nix.
Was haben wir als Attachments?
Haben wir noch irgendwas als Attachments?
Blinde Effekt? Hör mal bloß auf.
Okay, mein Ziel ist jetzt, ich sag euch was wir machen.
Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich campe jetzt an einem der M-Comps.
Und wenn einer kommt, dann kriegt er eine M320 Shotgun Ladung in your face.
Also sowas hier, sowas hier, guck, X und dann BÄM, und dann, ok, also Leute, das sollte
besser ordentlich Damage machen, das ist Single, das ist ein Single Schuss Shotgun mit ewig
langem Reload und insgesamt nur 3 Schuss, also, also jetzt mal seriously, wenn das nicht
krassen Damage macht, dann ist es ja useless, oh da ist ein, der Pants Man ist da, dann
dann ist es..
oi
HA
HAHA
ist das schlecht
oh gott ist das schlecht
defuse gear
Also das Ding ist aber richtig mies, ich mein guck mal, ich hab drei Schuss und so einen krassen Spread hat das nicht und ich hab dem Typ 5% Leben gemacht oder abgezogen oder sowas.
Okay, das ist ja aber ultra crap man.
Probier das jetzt nochmal aus.
Sehr schlau Max, richtig Poggers Play.
Excellent Poggerplay
Achtung!
Volle Pulle!
PP-Rat diffuse!
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Nein, nein, nein, Nein, Nein
ÄÄÄÄÄH
Was sind denn das für neue Granaten die da angezeigt werden?
Das, das war, das war irgendeine neue Granate
Das war nicht die, nicht die normale
Nee, da stand kein Geschütz. Das war doch irgend- das war so ein Radar oder sowas. Das war doch kein- war das ein Sentry-Gun gerade?
Seht ihr mal, wie pepega ich bin? Ich blick noch nicht mal durch, was ich- was ich überhaupt sehe.
Lul.
Ah, das war ein echtes Geschütz? Okay.
Ah, dann...
Ich dachte, das war irgendwie ein Radar oder sowas.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Oh, da drüben ist ein Gegner.
Das macht keinen Damage.
Fuck, ich hab's probiert, ich hab's probiert, beide.
Hm, na das ist nix.
LMGs sind ganz gut, ich glaube ich hab in dem Game noch nie ernsthaft LMGs gespielt.
Sollte man vielleicht, ich probiere gleich nochmal ein anderes Assault-Rifle aus.
Aber auch wieder ein klassisches Battlefield-3-Rifle, oder Battlefield-4, eins von beiden.
Ja okay, nee, als Defender ist die, das sagt niemand.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben...
Oh nee, da oben, jaja, jaja, okay.
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Das ist keine normale Granate oder SPH Explosive Launcher.
RM-68 ist noch OP, was ist denn das, ne SMG oder was ist das?
was ist denn das für ein ding?
Wir gammeln ein bisschen viel auf dem Dach, würde ich sagen, hä?
Wir sind ein bisschen zu krasse Dachgammler.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt hier runter, wir machen das jetzt folgendermaßen.
Ich würde den gerne retzen, kann ich aber nicht.
Nahkampf!
Geil!
Homeoffice ist Poggers, aber ich bin heute nicht im Homeoffice.
Der Respawn ist aber auch sehr, sehr...
Fuck, dachte man kann reload, man kann schneller switchen, vielleicht ist er noch auf dem Dach,
jawoll, bester Dude auf dem Dach hier der Typ, der ist nice, der Dachhocker, oh oh,
Da wirds ja alle wegstelzen mit der Pistole jetzt.
Alle, alle werden sie weggesprayt mit der Pistole von der Seite.
Als Attacker macht mir die Map eigentlich Bock.
Gerade das letzte Haus ist extrem nice.
So, wir, okay.
Ich muss, ich muss nochmal, Leute, ich muss nochmal diese komische Shotgun hier testen jetzt.
So, wo ist es denn hier? Achtung, Shotgun! Ey, das Ding ist so mies! Und es braucht ewig zum Nachladen!
Ich muss ein Shotgun... Leute, bevor ich diese Waffe wechsle, ich brauche ein Kill mit der Shotgun.
Ich will mal gucken, ob das Ding auch nur irgendeiner Art und Weise was taugt.
Okay, okay.
Nehmen.
Nee, das ist ein Geschütz.
Okay, Geschütze kann man damit anscheinend...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wo ist er?
Wo ist der Dude?
Nice!
Wenn man nicht treffen kann, muss man sich auch nicht beschweren.
Da kann die Shotgun jetzt nix für
Aber
Es steht ja schon im Titel, ihr sollt euch preparen für Pepega-Aim
Okay, pass auf
Messerkill, Messerkill
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt
Messerkill, Achtung, einen hab ich noch, einen hab ich noch
Oh shit, man
Messerkill. Ein Shotgun. Okay. Ziel, Ziel für die Runde. Shotgun Kill. Messerkill.
Ey man!
Alda!
Die Shotgun!
Ok, ein Schuss noch.
Ok, das Ding ist einfach nur mies.
Das ist einfach nur Müll, die Shotgun, Alda.
Auf die Range sollte die One-Shot...
Ok, wir testen, wir testen das andere.
Wir testen das andere.
Ähm...
Wir brauchen...
Dart ist ein bisschen range
Okay, das hier
Alles, okay
Bin mir nicht ganz ganz schlüssig, wo hier was ist. Bäm!
Alter Mann!
Wollen die mich veräppeln? Das Zeug macht ja überhaupt keinen Damage
Hopp, hopp, hopp
Shotgun
Okay, die ist schonmal besser
Die ist schonmal
Die ist schonmal besser
Als die Bugshot
Als die M360 Bugshot
Die geht schon irgendwie, okay?
Also damit kann man zumindest schonmal ein bisschen was killen
Easy Win, ok. Hat anscheinend gereicht.
Ne, also die Attachments, ich weiß nicht.
Ich mein, du brauchst ja ne Shotgun an nem Assault Rifle, also an nem Auto Assault Rifle.
Brauchst du daran keine Shotgun, die im Nahkampf quasi schlechter killt als das Assault-Rifle selbst.
Also das ist nix.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es...
Okay, Leute, es ist doch nicht blöd, das auszurüsten, weil so wie es aussieht, hat die Waffe...
Wir müssen mal die Griffe checken, ja?
So wie es aussieht, als hat die Waffe keinen sonderlich guten Attachments,
Attachments, so sind das immerhin 18 Bonus Schuss für eine Shotgun, die man einfach noch dabei bekommt.
Das sind alles echte Spieler, das waren keine Bots.
Man denkt das vielleicht bei manchen, oder bei mir auch zwischendurch manchmal.
Aber nee, nee, das sind keine... Wie aktiviert man denn XP-Boni?
Ähm, okay, im Booster, naja, close, hm, aber ich hab, ich hab, aktivieren die sich automatisch,
weil eben waren es nur noch 23 Minuten, ich glaub die aktivieren sich, die sind leider
direkt aktiv, sieht man mal auch wieder den Rückschritt von Battlefield 4, Battlefield
4 konntest du sagen, ey, ich hab jetzt mal 5, 6 Stunden Zeit, kann richtig hardcore grinden,
Dann hast du deinen XP-Booster angemacht, oder auch die Waffenbooster an den, wenn du für die Waffen, die, wieder, beste, nice!
DLC-Map, oder, naja, DL, nein, nicht DLC, DLC, Season-Map.
Mal gucken, was wir jetzt sind. Lass mal eine andere Waffe ausprobieren, BF3 aber, AN-490.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zum Attachen?
Ähm...
Ein Suppressor, okay.
Und Griffke
Will ich gar kein Griffke haben. Griffke, alter
Extended Mag
Und was haben wir denn hier?
Holo
Nee, das ist okay so.
Ach, es geht schon los!
Okay, machen wir mal Suppressor dran, das da und Code Revisier.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, na geil! Beste! Reingespawnt, Attachments drauf, kommst und du schon um die Ecke geflitzt.
Okay, es scheint mir so ein bisschen Flank-Action auf B zu gehen.
zu gehen
Deswegen stellen wir uns mal kurz hier lang
Die kommen garantiert wieder über die...
die Bahn kommt da vorne gerade
Nein! Nein nein nein nein...
Es hat kaum Damage gemacht, Lul
Was denn?!
Die Sackt, die Sackt auf Range extrem mit dem Schalldämpfer, kannst vergessen.
Ich hab Schiss, ich hab Schiss, ich verpiss mich mal hier kurz, na gut, aber wir machen.
Nee, die suckt mit Silencer, die kann man nicht spielen mit Silencer, das ist Müll.
Das ist Müll mit Silencer.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, die kannst du nicht spielen mit Silencer, die macht viel zu wenig Damage
und viel zu viel rumgewackelt auf range
die müssen wir ohne silencer spielen
ähm
ja es ist nicht schlecht, wenn sie dich nicht sehen, das stimmt schon
also wenn sie dich auf dem Radar nicht sehen
aber die andere
ist besser, die andere ist auf jeden Fall besser
für stealth action
guck mal wie ewig das dauert
man
Ich höre was rennen übrigens hier neben uns, oh oh
Okay, der könnte mich retzen, der ist direkt neben mir, der haben auch keine Sicht, keine
Sicht auf den
Retzke!
Jawoll, Medic!
Nicer Medic, Oma!
Ok, ich seh hier grad nix
Bock, Alter!
Die ist wirklich nix mit Silencer
Ne, das Ding ist, das Ding ist übelst
RM48
äh 68
Was ist denn das für eine?
Ist das ein SMG? Ist das ein Assault Rifle? Man erkennt das bei den Dingern nicht.
Ich mach den Schalldämpfer ab.
Also das sagt... das gefällt mir nicht.
Die Kombi gefällt mir nicht.
Das andere war ganz nice, aber das war nix.
So.
Ohne Seilanzer ist die eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay, nice.
Irgendwo hier ist was. Ich seh bloß nicht genau wo. Kurz Kopf. Ne, das sind meine Dudes.
Was ist denn die letzte Waffe? Leute, ich hab das letzte nicht richtig gespielt, weil mein Spiel nicht gestartet ist.
Aber geht jetzt ja anscheinend wieder.
50%!
Oh, da war was. Da ist was.
Shit, alter die Assault-Rifles, die sind ja immer auf Range, das ist richtig mies.
Oh, da war noch mehr, ich hab's.
Shit, die hätte ich alle haben können. Der kommt zu mir.
Reload, Reload.
Fuck, ich hab unter mir einen gehört und wollte mich rumdrehen.
Aber immerhin.
Also das Ding geht ohne Silencer ganz gut, klar.
Aber mit S...
Oh, die haben das auch noch.
R? Okay, wo gibt's die?
R?
RM68.
Er M 68 ist das ist das sind es soll trifle nene
Was ist denn das
Ach, nee hier sehe ich ja hier ich sehe ja nur die anlockten ich habe ich habe sie nur ja gelockt
Ist das, ist das... Chat, Chat, ich hab's immer noch nicht gecheckt. Ist das ein Assault Rifle? Hä? Ist das ein Assault Rifle?
Ah ja, okay. Dann muss ich mal kurz gucken, gleich nach der Runde, was man da anlocken kann.
Ab und zu muss man auch mal ein bisschen OP-Zeug spielen.
Ja letztlich, wie gesagt, letztes Season konnte ich nicht spielen, da ist mein Game einfach
nicht gestartet.
Oder nicht, richtig.
Wo sind die?
Wo ist denn hier was?
Eher Richtung A, hm?
KDL
Sagt doch, preparet euch für ein
härtestes
PPGAIM
Aber gut
Jetzt wissen wir zumindest auf welcher Seite sie pushen
Geht gut was an A ab
Ich wäre auch gerne mal wieder
Attacker, das macht mir einfach mehr Bock.
Shit, das ist nix.
Das ist nix, ich glaube ich schwenke wieder um auf die M416.
M416, welche waren das jetzt hier?
Gut, das haben sie.
Jetzt können wir nur die Shotgun rausholen
Ich mein es ist ganz nice ne Shotgun dabei zu haben für sowas
Oh wir müssen unbedingt auf B rüber
Vielleicht komm ich hier nochmal rein, aber ich glaub's nicht.
Ne, ne. Ich glaub, der ist dead.
Wir müssen unbedingt auf B rüber.
Oh!
Die Cluster-Granate...
Die haben sie doch genervt, war da nicht was?
Wurd... Wurd... Wurd die nicht... Wurd die nicht irgendwie angepasst?
Ich glaube, die Cluster...
Ne! Die Cluster-Granate selbst ist, glaub ich, noch...
Oh! Nice. Ich dachte, da ist ein Dach.
Die Cluster-Granate ist noch das gleiche, aber...
... wie oft man die benutzen...
Okay, und tschüss.
Ich möchte aufs Dach hoch.
Nice.
Okay, wenn ich...
Komm raus, komm raus.
Komm raus.
Ich weiß, dass du dahinter bist.
Kollege.
Der
machen.
Die Fuse-Gear müssen wir machen.
Aber, wir...
Okay, nicer Dude, 5-Header
Oh, die hätte ich sprayen können, hätte ich ein paar Sekunden länger Zeit gehabt
Das hätten einfach 5 Leute an irgendeiner Nase
Ja gut, da kannst du nichts machen, wenn du vor drei Gegnern stehst, direkt in Sichtlinie.
Nice!
Immerhin, an mir liegt's nicht.
Geh mal schauen, also das hier zu campen ist glaube ich eine echt bescheuerte Idee.
Wir können hier auch absolut Null vorpushen, weil die Grenze von der Map halt so ungünstig für uns gelegen ist.
Die andere Seite ist eigentlich ganz gut, weil sonst könntest du hier halt spawn raiten ohne Ende.
Ey, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Okay, man muss auf jeden Fall tappen, sonst ist man...
Wenn man das nicht tappt auf mittlere Range, ist man richtig gefickt.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, ich weiß wo du bist.
von der seite immer da wo man nicht hinguckt krieg ich ein rätsel
jetzt oma oma jawoll medik oma please please jawoll jawoll
dimas jawoll nee oder noch besser hier nico
Richtiger Poggers-Dude. MVP-Niko am Start.
Richtiger Macher, wie man das so schön sagt heutzutage.
Boah, mein Bein!
Nein!
Du spielst nur die Reds, Oma. Ich, ich mag den...
Der Reload ist viel zu lang.
Find ich auch. Das wirkt nicht nur so.
Gerade mit Extended Mag, das dauert ewig, bis du da reloadet hast.
Hallo?
Treffen, please.
Ja gut, dann rennt ihr nur schön an mir vorbei, ohne zu gucken, man.
Rechte Seite geht's wohl eher ab gerade.
Shit, zu spät gesehen.
Pepega29, taugt das Ding mittlerweile wieder was?
Ist das wieder gut? Das war ja die OP-Waffe überhaupt in der ersten, so in den ersten paar Wochen.
Oh, shit.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo er ist, welche Seite.
Da ist noch einer. Da ist auf jeden Fall noch einer.
Ich hör einen über mir. Ich muss da jetzt...
Nice. Nein! Fuck it!
Ah, da ist noch einer. Shit!
Ich, weil ich hab hinter mir einen gehört.
Den hätte ich auf jeden fall nicht mehr erwischt ich muss jetzt darüber ich dachte nicht dass da noch ein zweiter ist
Aber da machst du nix
Kann ich nicht letzen oder doch kann ich
Nice
Fack, Fack, Fack, Fack
Ich hau' da mal ab.
Von wo?
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Manchmal, manchmal muss man ein bisschen den Stelzmodus aktivieren im Battlefield.
Manchmal, manchmal geht's halt anders.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay
Sehr gut Max
Mehr PP geaimt
Ich weiß nicht
Ihr wisst aber auch nicht wo ich bin
Lulbe
Keckel extrem
das war ja was man wir haben uns gerade übertroffen im ppga aim das war jetzt ppga aim world
Championship gerade!
Blöde Idee Max, ganz blöde Idee!
Ganz blöde Idee, ganz blöde Idee, ganz schlechte Idee!
Ich bin vor dir!
Du bist ein Arschloch!
Mega-Entertainment-Championship, aber wirklich gerade krass.
War da unter mir einer?
wenigstens
wenigstens einfach
career best
leute wir haben das
high performer mindset offensichtlich gerade
aktiviert
ich hatte aber sogar
das stimmt überhaupt nicht das es career best ist
ich hatte sogar schon
videos auf youtube da hatte ich deutlich mehr
assault rifle kills pro runde
das ist ja auch nur ne rush runde, ne rush runde geht ja auch viel kürzer
aber ich hatte schon
Runden auf YouTube mit mehr Kills.
Ich hätte glaube ich mal eine 54-Kill-Runde rushed. Also, was soll ich? Vielleicht mit der Waffe auf der Map in der Kombination oder sowas.
Jetzt geht die Progression, Leute! Die Progression, die richtig high-performed.
Ne, das sah aus, als wären es zwei Level oder drei Level, aber es war nur eins.
Guck mal jetzt, ach ja, genau.
Kollektion
Kq 46 das ding na ok
rm
68 unlock was muss man dafür machen
Leute wie ist eigentlich die streamqualität und und die
Wie flüssig das ist und sowas ich habe die ich habe die bandbreite hochgestellt also es sollte wirklich
keine großen Artefakte geben. Battle Pass Tier 40. Ah, okay.
Aber der aktuelle Battle Pass auch oder der letzte Battle Pass?
Man wird das ja mit Sicherheit noch anlocken können.
Ja gut, aber diesen vier Battle Pass gibt es doch nicht mehr.
Oder kann man die nachträglich irgendwie machen noch?
Ich bin mega planlos was das angeht
Wir müssen mal schauen gleich, erinnert mich mal please nach der Runde dran, dass ich nochmal gucke
Wie man das, wie man das macht, wie man die unlockt jetzt. So die pushen garantiert auf A erstmal
Deswegen gehen wir auf A, weil auch, okay nein
Ey, hab nichts gesagt
Ja, ich gucke gleich mal in die sammlung. Ja, so machen wir das
Vielleicht gehe ich auch einfach aus der runde raus
Erste base ist immer pp. Gar extreme extrem. Die schon bb. Gar ist das schon
Wuuuuh
Krieg ich eh- Oh da ist einer
Ja geiler Schneiber Dude, man
Oh da ist noch einer
Hä?
Chat, war das Boomer Augen oder habt ihr den auch nicht gesehen?
Kombination wahrscheinlich, ja.
Du hast den auch nicht gesehen.
Au!
Okay
Alter, sag mal
Du machst ja hier gar nichts
Außer verrecken
Da hinten ist übrigens einer, oder?
What?
Leute, ich blick nicht mehr durch
Wo gerade was abgeht
Ich geh jetzt einfach mal hier hin
Guck da mal um die Ecke
Und freu mich, dass hier
Da war einer übrigens links
das hier
da war einer übrigens links
easy
oder auch nicht
das sind jetzt wirklich ESL-Final-Lobbys wieder
das ist wirklich ESL-Finals
wir sollten, eigentlich sollte ich auf Engineer switchen, dass wir die Dinger
platt machen können, aber
das ist gar nicht so notwendig
Weil wir können das alles wieder wettmachen in der Fabrik gleich.
Alles kein Ding.
Okay.
Wir können das in der Fabrik alles wieder...
Aber ich hab die RM68 nicht unlockt, Leute.
Hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Ich konnte letzte Season das Game nicht spielen, weil ich das Game nicht starten konnte.
Weil DICE sich gedacht hat, nee.
Der Max, der hat das Game gekauft und will es spielen, aber das geht nicht.
Der basht zu sehr.
Alter Tryhard basht junge Noobs und das wollen wir nicht.
Das ist nicht...
Dabei.
Woran hänge ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Schnitzelpork...
Ey, da hätte ich mal richtig Bock drauf wieder, Leute.
Okay, nice.
Da hätte ich mal richtig Bock drauf.
Schnitzel, Zwiebel, Bratkartoffel.
Da hätte ich massives Bock drauf.
Sag ich euch.
Okay.
Ich hab extrem Bock drauf.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt mal hier hinter,
weil ich die, weil ich die kleinen PP-Gas kenne.
Was?!
Lege Henne!
Jetzt schon!
Shit.
Okay, das wird schwierig, die Runde.
Das ist wirklich ESL Finals jetzt.
Wo sind wir hier eigentlich?
Wo bin ich denn hier?
Hier war ich ja ernsthaft noch nie!
Wo bin ich?
Ich will zu den Mk-
Wo bin ich überhaupt?
Okay
Alter!
Schlaganfall-Time!
Ne?
Das Game hat nicht nur random nicht gestartet
Das Game hat nicht nur random nicht gestartet, das hat gar nicht gestartet
Das hat einfach Season 4 nicht gestartet
Ich hab's, wir haben's doch sogar im Stream hier ausprobiert
Das ging einfach nicht
Das ist einfach nicht gestartet
Sogar nicht gestartet
Einfach gar nicht. Was war denn das?
Habt ihr das grad...
Habt ihr das grad fliegen sehen?
An mir vorbei?
Was war das denn? War das irgendeine Radar?
Aufklärungsdrohne?
Ich hab so keine Ahnung mehr von dem Game.
Das ist krass.
Gut, ich mein, es ist auch nicht so, als hätte ich es wahnsinnig viel gespielt.
Ich glaube, ich hab knapp 100 Stunden.
Das ist halt nix für Battlefield.
Also, bei normalen Spielzeilen.
Was Battlefield Games angeht.
Die ganze Runde Breakthroughs, stimmt du hast recht das machen wir gleich, wir anlocken gleich die Waffe, ja gute Idee, Chatge, Pfeifferdertime, richtig Pfeifferd, wir anlocken gleich alles.
Okay, fuck. Ich dachte er ist dead.
Letzter dead.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Hier noch einer.
Oh oh, oh shit.
Ich dachte da läuft noch einer.
Nice.
By the way, den hab ich nicht richtig gesehen.
Okay, nice.
Das ist oder wenn mir sobald mich der tank sieht bin ich bin ich fakt
So richtig
So richtig fakt
Okay jetzt jetzt bin ich
Aber wir haben doch wirklich ich glaube wir haben gerade fünf stücke oder so gekillt im ein da sollten sie jetzt wenigstens bräge nicht direkt das mcom legen
Oh oh, hinter mir.
Okay, das wird schwierig, da wieder fortzukommen.
Okay, okay, wo kommt er? Wo kommt er?
Okay, die wissen, dass ich da bin, auf jeden Fall.
Recht, links?
Woah!
Alter, please!
Sniper-Shit, man! Was soll das?
Den Kill hat er nicht verdient.
Ich hab den im Rennen schon abgeballert.
Im Rennen schon abgeballert und dann macht der irgendeinen komischen Hüften-No-Scope-Shit
Was ein Müll
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, pass mal auf. Ich camp hier jetzt mit der Shotgun
What the hell?
Der Typ, man
Jetzt rennt der da auch mit ner Shotgun rum, Alter!
Ich, ich, hab, hab ich die auch? Ist das ne Pistole?
Leute, ist das ne Pistole, diese, die Mini-Shotgun, oder was ist das?
Oh oh, wir sind deadge.
Oh, nein, wir sind nicht deadge.
Oh, wir sind sowas von deadge.
Das ist ne Pistole. Ok, das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Ich muss anlocken gleich.
RM-68 und Shotgun-Pistole.
Okay, das ist nicht die letzte Base normalerweise.
Ist das jetzt neuerdings die letzte Base?
Outstanding Kills, jawoll.
Okay, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Das müssen wir gleich mal checken, gehen wir mal aus der Queue hier raus, mit 1700 FPS,
habe ich ihn unlocked?
Gar nicht, aber ich zeig mal erstmal irgendwas spannendes, was ich unlocked habe für das
Ding.
M, wo ist es denn?
Ja, M416.
Ach, das ist gar kein Suppressor.
Suppressor.
Den hier habe ich bloß noch zum Anlocken.
Okay.
Ähm, also, okay, wo gibt's das, wo gibt's das Teil zum Anlocken?
rm
68 man braucht kills and assists with m5 a3
Headshot easy ja das haben wir ja
das haben wir ja das haben wir ja
0, nix
Gedenkst du ja m m 5 16 wir spielen eine runde m 5
Nehmen ich m 5 16 m 5 a 3 dann haben wir das anmacht so und wo ist die shotgun pistol
super 500
Man braucht Kills with Shotguns
Kriegen wir auch easy?
Ne ne, Kills with secondary weapons
Und Kills and Assists with Shotguns
Dann brauche ich wahrscheinlich ernsthaft das Ding
Oder es gibt ja nur eine Shotgun in dem Spiel
Ah ne, das gibt es auch noch
Ja das wird
Das wird abfucked
Aber man braucht zum Glück nicht viel
Man braucht zum Glück nicht viel
Ja easy
Das machen wir jetzt schnell
Das geht sehr zackig
Das geht sehr zackig, also wir brauchen 30 Kills mit Shotguns, das ist innerhalb von 2-3 Minuten haben wir das fertig, na ok 5 Minuten haben wir das fertig
Und wir brauchen, was hatte ich gesagt?
Ach, easy, das machen wir jetzt, das machen wir jetzt, das geht Leute, also wenn ihr euch fragt wie man Sachen unlockt, am besten
So
Easy as fuck
Es dauert 5 Minuten, dann haben wir das freigeschaltet.
Ich hoffe ihr habt es euch gemerkt, weil ich habe es mir nicht gemerkt.
3 waren es 25, 25 oder 30 Shotgun Kills.
30 oder?
30, okay, easy, Eats, Eats 30 Shotgun Kills.
Zählt das auch als Shotgun?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Okay und secondary Kills.
Und das andere waren 25 M5A3 Kills. Ja, das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Easy.
In South Korea sind wir.
Autoshotgun. Stimmt, die habe ich auch noch nicht frei gespielt. Ich spiele halt eigentlich nur die Dinger frei.
Ach, secondary Kills über 25 Meter. Kriege ich auch hin.
Ich spiele halt eigentlich so gut wie nie Shotguns in dem game ich finde es auch meistens nicht sinnvoll wenn die sniper
Challenges und shotgun challenges machen weil das sind beide schon so mit die größten abfahrt abfahrt waffen in dem game
plus das ist gerade wenn man rush spielt
Ziemlich ziemlich lehmt so eine runde wenn du dann irgendwie erst mal
90 leute 90 prozent des teams die da sitzen und in der base und irgendwie ihre 360 sniper challenge machen
Ja
Wobei gibt es den Trick überhaupt noch?
Sich aufs Dach legen und die Beine der Gegner wegbashen?
Ich glaube das geht gar nicht mehr
Ich glaube das ist
Ist das über 25 Meter jetzt?
Sekunde wir müssen mal kurz hier ran
und ein paar Gegner killen
Ist das über 25 Meter jetzt?
Sekunde, wir müssen mal kurz hier ran und ein paar Gegner killen.
Okay.
Okay, das dauert doch länger als ich gedacht hab.
Vielleicht machen wir das doch nicht.
Ich muss da ein bisschen...
Ich muss da ein bisschen näher dran.
Aber es geht schnell.
Was ich übrigens auch sehr merkwürdig finde,
dass das Anlocken...
Das ist das Anlocken gegen Bots funktioniert, btw. Guck mal, wir haben schon ein Drittel, easy.
Gehts das?
Brauch ich denn mal Muni?
ah ok die hälfte haben wir schon das geht wirklich schnell leute die hälfte
der die hälfte der shotgun kills haben wir schon
ja aber ganz ehrlich ich finde das stellt ein bisschen also dann sollten sie
die unlocks weglassen ganz ehrlich was ist der sinn von unlocks wenn du es
einfach in zwei minuten gegen bots machen kannst dann kannst du die unlocks
weglassen
Alternativ wenn du sagst es dauert so lange gegen echte spieler sollte man die anlogs ein bisschen runter schrauben ich finde es vom design her einfach
nur ppga hängen geblieben
bisschen versteht ihr wie ich meine also wenn du anlogs machst dann halt nur gegen echte spieler warum gegen bots ist komplett sinnlos weil
dann geht jeder in die bots in die bot matches rein und spielt hat fünf minuten bot match nach die sachen anlog
damit du elite kaufst
leute wisst ihr das dumme ist ihr habt recht
ihr habt
ihr habt ihr habt wahrscheinlich
Komplett recht das ist irgend so ein dlc anreizkauf shit
Okay range kills
Oh nice nice krasses aim oder leute krasses aim krassestes aim ever
Krassestes aim, besser geht das nicht
Mehr ist es einfach top absolut peak aiming peak
Okay, das sollten die 25 Meter Kills sein.
Alter, what the fuck, okay die Shotgun suckt im Range.
Okay, 8 Kills noch, dann haben wir es.
Ja, das war schon seit Release so.
Okay, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, auf was du dich beziehst im Chat, aber ich meine nur
Guck mal ob du tatsächlich Fortschritt beim Anloggen machst. Mach ich.
Ich weiß, die Bots zählen.
Definitiv. Weiß ich.
Ich seh grad nix.
Wo sind, wo sind...
Gegners
Gleich haben wir es Leute
Und dann noch 25 Kills
Ok
Oh Shit noch 3 Kills mit der Shotgun
War das gestern ein Bug?
Ok
Es wäre in der Tat sehr doof wenn das nicht zählen würde
Wisst ihr ob die
Wisst ihr ob die Unlocks angezeigt werden?
Wenn man die freigeschaltet hat, werden die ingame angezeigt oder erst wenn man aus der Runde raus geht.
Gibt es kurzes... okay, Chatge, dann achtet mal kurz drauf, ob das angezeigt wird.
Wurde gerade was angezeigt?
Das müsste jetzt auf jeden Fall reichen.
Das müsste reichen, jetzt brauchen wir noch 25 Kills, M5.
Ach, man kann direkt hier in der Collection, ach, Chat, MVP, wo ist es denn hier?
Das Ding
Ja, aber in Shotguns wollte ich gucken
Yep, nice, okay
Wir brauchen noch, gut, easy, haben wir. Jetzt brauchen wir noch 25 Kills mit der M5A3
Keine Ahnung, was man da am besten ausrüstet, habe ich nicht gespielt.
Also es heißt, wir haben 48, sagen wir mal 50, 75, ok, 3-4 Minuten, dann haben wir das auch.
Ja, ja, ist gut. Lass mich in Ruhe.
Wodka.
Das Ding, sag mal, das Ding verzieht null, oder?
Verzieht halt einfach gar nicht im Vergleich zu M416.
das ist einfach komplett statisch
ist das verbuggt?
guck mal, leute
das ist einfach komplett statisch
statische
So, gleich 10 Stück noch, dann haben wir alles anloggt.
Das verzieht wirklich gar nicht!
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Absicht ist.
Einfach hier mal sitzen bleiben.
GG Eats.
Bots, ja.
Ah ja, ich will anlocken.
Besser...
Besser als drei Stunden spielen jetzt erstmal, bis ich die Sachen ausprobiert hab.
Okay, haben wir es? Ne, ach Mist.
Range Kill?
Wollen wir einen Range Kill? Range Kill brauchen wir noch.
Der hat keinen Bock mehr.
Da hat kein Bock mehr
Ok 5 Kills noch
Dann haben wir es geschafft
Ist halt das Ding
Wirklich Spaß machen gegen Bots tut es net
Aber besser als 3 Stunden spielen
Ok
Nice
Sehr gutes Ding mit der Pistole.
Okay, Ragekill.
Zählt das? Ich hoffe.
Meint ihr, das waren 25 Meter?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich unlocke nur.
Leute, ich spiele nicht absichtlich jetzt hier gegen Bots,
weil ich denke, das klappt sonst nicht.
Wir haben schon auch... Das ist die erste Runde
gegen Bots, um schnell Unlocks zu machen.
Unlockge...
Wir haben es gleich noch drei kills wo wollen die eigentlich gerade hin
Die wollen zum spawn zurück weil irgendwie das game ihnen sagt
Okay der hier 25 meter oder 25 meter
okay wir sollten wir sollten es haben ich war jetzt noch drei bonus kills oder so
wobei wie war das escape collection wie ach moment 25 meter
chat was habt ihr mir da wieder für zeug erzählt
Okay, das Ding haben wir.
Richtig richtig PPGaChat wieder.
Okay, 25 on less, ja meine Güte.
So, jetzt haben wir alles unlocked gleich.
Ich hätte es schon letzt gehabt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es aber, oder?
Hat es jetzt gezählt?
Das war jetzt unter 55, jawoll, nice, easy.
Okay, dann mal kurz equipen.
Nee, nicht equipen, einfach rausgehen, fertig.
Jawoll, weiter geht's, rusch!
Sie wissen, wie lange hat es jetzt gedauert, Leute?
10 Minuten höchstens und das ist halt das, was ich meine, wenn du Unlocks in das Game einbaust
Das ist ja schön und gut, ne? Ich meine, viele Leute, ich bräuchte es nicht, ich hätte nichts dagegen, wenn alles direkt accessible wäre
Aber wenn du Unlocks in das Game einbaust, dann sollte es echt nur gegen echte Spieler funktionieren
Weil sonst machen die Leute das so wie ich, die gehen in ein Bot-Game, spielen fünf bis zehn Minuten und
Anlocken was auch bescheuert ist also entweder gibst du den leuten einfach alles oder du packst alles an einen battle pass meinetwegen
Ich hätte auch keine probleme mit wenn das alles anlockt ist
Ich meine früher in den games war es ja meistens so dass die waffen an
Level gebunden war ansonsten nix
Das finde ich okay
Ja das finde ich okay
Ich meine gut, könntest du sagen, ja, machst du halt XP-Grinds versus Bots, gibt's bestimmt immer noch irgendwelche Portal-Server, wo das total easy geht, dass du massig XP machst.
Ich seh das ähnlich wie Meester P, also wenn das Game langweilig ist, ohne Unlocks, dann ist das Game wahrscheinlich kacke.
Der anderen Seite, wenn ein Game motivierend ist, es kann durchaus cool sein, wenn du ein paar Sachen anlocken kannst.
Ich persönlich find's ja besser, wenn du irgendwelche coolen Gimmicks anlocken kannst, ja?
Leider werden heute halt alle Gimmicks in irgendwie... Och, mh.
Ich find Caspian Border funktioniert in Battlefield 2042 nicht richtig.
Also ich mein, guckt euch beispielsweise mal an in CoD 4, war's mega nice, wenn du beispielsweise...
Ah nice, die Runde ist vorbei. Easy.
Ähm, ne, fuck, die geht jetzt jetzt los.
Haha.
Äh, fand ich's mega nice, wenn man...
...die goldene Desert Eagle, goldene LMG und so Zeug anlockt hat.
Okay, das Ding ist jetzt, das Ding ist OPAF oder wie ist das?
Seh ich das richtig?
Und wir machen jetzt hier mal...
...gib mir die Shotgun.
Ich glaube, groß zu attachen...
Ah, die hat standardmäßig einen Schalldämpfer drauf und Lasert, ja.
Das ist natürlich schon mal...
Pog
Pog G ist das
Gibt es vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
Schuss
Ok
Schauen wir mal
Wow
Igitt, was ist denn
Was ist das für ein Visier
Das will ich nicht spielen
Lass mich mal kurz
Lass mich mal kurz wipen und das ich ein anderes Visier
Ja, jawoll, schieß mich. Mach mich kaputt. Jawoll. Pog, danke.
Anderes Visier, please.
Wobei, dafür hätte ich gar nicht sterben müssen.
Ich kann nur...
Äh, wie jetzt? Gibt's net?
Hat die nur so Müllvisiere oder was?
Ja, Fusion-Holo, wenn schon, denn schon, irgendwann mal.
Iron Sight kann man mit F, seht ihr mal, ihr blickt richtig, richtig Poggers durch.
Woah, woah, das ist jetzt aber auch nicht viel schöner.
Das irritiert mich ja extrem, wenn ich so spielen muss.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt noch mal 30 Kills oder so machen mit Bots für das andere Visier.
Moment, die haben schon die Legehände gemacht.
Die haben schon gelegt!
Ich finde, die Map funktioniert nicht in dem Game.
Ich glaube, der ist mit seinem Kopf selbst in die Bullets reingerannt gerade.
Sind eigentlich, äh, das ist auch was, ähm, sind Jets und Helis jetzt eigentlich immer
noch auf dem gleichen Slot, sodass eigentlich du dein Team nur abfuckst, wenn du überhaupt
nen
Jet pickst?
Da ist noch einer drin, oder?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, ich spring da jetzt rein und der Dude steht hier.
Aber ist nicht so.
So, wo sind denn die jetzt? Sind die an A?
Die sind an A.
Okay, die mag ich nicht, die hat eine krasse Trauma-Frange.
Krieg ich den Rats?
Rats, please.
Jawoll, Oma, Dankeschön, Fogu.
Aber es ist gut.
Ehrlich gesagt, es ist gut, dass die Shotgun nur so kurze Range hat.
Der hat mich jetzt ein bisschen genervt, weil ich grad nichts gekillt hab, aber ganz im Ernst, stellt euch mal vor, die Shotgun würde da hinten irgendwie am Baum einen hitten oder so, das wäre ja auch bescheuert, ne?
Ich sollte mich mal kurz... Oh, da ist einer gedroppt.
Dropped
Oh da kommt noch einer
Muss man mal kurz hier abcampen
Keiner mehr da
Gehen wir mal zu...
Ah war B, B, B, B, B, B
Legehennen
Wo ist er?
Ist er, ist er im...
Ey
Ich dachte er ist im Bus
Der war doch, der war doch dahinten
Diffuske. Diffuske, nice. Denkst du es nochmal an wirklich letztes Berlin? Ach ich glaube schon. Vielleicht, Leute. Ich glaube wir hatten ja ein paar ganz brauchbare Szenen, na nice. Wir hatten ja ein paar ganz brauchbare Szenen heute im Stream bis jetzt schon.
Also vielleicht schneide ich da irgendwas draus zusammen.
Liegt da einer?
Okay, muss ich sagen, in dem Fall hat sich das Visier doch mal gelohnt.
Auch wenn ich, wenn ich diese, die A-Cock-Visiere nicht mag.
Pass auf, die banen wir jetzt!
Hehehehehehe
Oh
Lege! Diffuse, Hannah!
Gib ihm!
Win!
12-1, nice!
Ja, das war's!
Das war's!
Nice!
Yep, ACOG!
Urgh!
Mal gucken, ob ich, ähm, eine Würdigung in den Credits bekomme.
Most Revives, alles gut.
M-Coms, Diffusers und...
Old-Stanley-Performer.
Nein, wie? Moin!
Das war der falsche Name?
Das...
Da stand ein anderer Name dran, aber mit meiner Kill-Anzahl.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ja, da stand... Wer ist denn... Ist Renix überhaupt in dem Game drin?
Ach hier der dritte. Ach der hat auch 12. Ach das, guck mal der hat eine bessere KD als
ich. Okay fair, fair, ist okay, ist gut, in Ordnung. Ich hatte zwar insgesamt mit paar
Diffuses und so finde ich die bessere Rundenperformance, aber ich will mich jetzt mal nicht so sehr
Beschweren a holo beste müssen wir gleich müssen wir gleich equip gleich equippen
Wissen wir mit zwei kills auf dem zweiten platz der ist wahrscheinlich die ganze zeit im kreis gerast an leute wiederbelebt
Vermutlich
Oder es war einer von den Panzer-Dudes, oder der Heli, vielleicht war das auch, ne der Heli war im Attacker-Team, gar keiner, im Heli-Pilot.
Finde ich auch gut, irgendwie muss es ja auch einen Anreiz geben für die Leute, Panzer zu reparieren.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, wie oft, jetzt mal Real Talk, sagt mal ehrlich, wie oft habt ihr in Battlefield 2042 gesehen, dass jemand Panzer repariert hat?
Also ich kann mich an keinen Vorfall erinnern, vielleicht unbewusst 3-4 mal, wenn es hochkommt, in dem Spiel repariert niemand Panzer. Keiner.
Das Holo ist deutlich besser. Ja, aber ich hab das Holo noch nicht unlockt.
das ähm
kommt irgendwie erst mit 30 Kills oder so
ab und zu vor
aber auch jetzt erst seit
seitdem sie ein bisschen was gepatcht haben
also am Anfang hat da nie jemand
irgendwas
ich geh mal mit rein
das ist immer, ich bin so ein krasser Noob in dem Game
ich weiß noch nicht mal was das hier ist was ich da habe
Smoke oder
Oder Fahrzeug lasern oder spotten oder was kann ich hier überhaupt machen mit also mit g kann ich glaube ich proximity sensors machen
Spotter
Den ich habe den gespottet schon wieder gebastler
Ich bin unsicher was mich eigentlich gerade gekillt hat
Eine Brandgranate wahrscheinlich
So pass mal auf wir sind jetzt ein bisschen lebensmüde
Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen lebensmüde
Sind wir tatsächlich
Ich wollte eigentlich sagen wir sind jetzt ein bisschen lebensmüde
Und versuchen rauf aufs Dach zu
PP garen
Mal gucken ob wir das hinkriegen
Ich hoffe da kommt jetzt nichts von hinten gleich, pass mal auf, Trick 17.
Fuck it!
Der Crumbling-Hook hat nicht so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab.
Leider.
Wär ganz nicer Play gewesen, oder?
Fuck.
Hahaha, in den Kopf geschossen!
Bin ich...
Er hat Zange!
Ja
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Sehr schlau.
Nein, nein, nein, nein!
Nein! Shit!
Meine Munition war leer!
Ich hätte vier Stück jetzt einfach Hüft sprayen können!
Shit, Alter!
Ah, na gut.
Kann nicht alles klappen, kann ja nicht alles klappen.
Au, au, die sprengen uns die Luft gleich.
Ich muss mal kurz verpissen. Hier rüber, aufs Dach, rauf und dann hoffen, dass da oben keiner rumkämpft von denen, was keiner macht glücklicherweise.
Okay, hier unten ist alles down. Okay, anscheinend alles weg.
Der Grappling-Hook sieht immer noch sehr klar... Ja.
War das PP'ger Aim oder hat's einfach nicht gehittet?
Schei... Oh, oh, von hinten. Wir werden gleich in die Luft gesprengt. Shit, ich muss raus.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit. Lass mich in Ruhe.
Nice
Shit
Den hätte ich haben müssen
Ich hätte wissen müssen, dass der jetzt
Oh Twitch
Leute
Ich wurde gerade
Wurde gerade weggebashed
Live on stream
Rückts wahrscheinlich
Wo ist der Dude?
Ey man!
Okay nice
Hab ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich dieses Visier
absolut nicht mag?
Treff mir den Dinger nix
So
Shit
Gut, das Ding ist wirklich nice, weil es einen eingebauten Schalldämpfer hat, muss ich sagen.
Ich glaube, mit einem ordentlichen Visier, wäre das jetzt nochmal ein Doppel-Pog.
Und zu wenig Schuss.
Alter, sagt das mal.
Ey, what the fuck, was ist das für ein Visier, man?
Da ist auch keiner da, der mich retzen kann.
Also ich glaube, ich muss da echt noch ein bisschen was anlocken.
Die Waffe ist geil mit eingebautem, hier komm her, mit eingebautem Schalldämpfer,
ist schon sehr nice.
Und die ist ziemlich akkurat.
muss man bei wo muss man eigentlich hinschießen bei diesem ding auf die
spitze oder zwischenspitze und auf den pfeil untendran so leicht unter die
spitze oder so in in in die muss man muss man den gegner so haben oder so
haben
also müssen die in diesem dreieck drin sein oder auf der spitze vom dreieck
Falls, falls irgendjemand von euch das weiß.
Au!
Auf der Spitze?
Na, da hatte ich den eigentlich eben.
Fuck, ich hab zu wenig Leben, ich muss warten bis der...
Wir, wir switchen, wir switchen mal kurz.
Ich brauch ein bisschen was mit mehr Schuss.
Schuss. Lasst mal kurz wieder zurückgehen auf die M416. Und jetzt volle Pulle mit dem
jeep
hmm
jawoll
geb ihm
ja fahren jetzt einfach hier drüber
und jetzt
jetzt probieren wir es
also hier unten ist
wenn die mich jetzt hier nicht rausholen
shit shit shit shit
hier unten ist eigentlich
ex
extremely
hog
da denkt nie einer
dass man da ist
nie
Die checken es immer nicht, wenn man hier ist.
Guck hier, der auch nicht.
Fuck, ich bin voll reingerannt.
In den Schuss, ja.
Oh, der hätte mich retzen können.
Nope.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, rein, rein, rein.
Ach, wir haben es.
Ne, wir haben es nicht.
Dachte, wir haben es.
Oh, da drinnen ist...
Da drinnen ist voll.
auf der spitze, die runde läuft gar net, no pass, aber so ist es halt manchmal, manchmal
machst du nix
Gott ey meine güte wie schlecht
Jetzt leute nach zwei stunden setzt das ppga aim ein
Aber wir haben es okay glücklicherweise
Haben es meine teams diese runde gerissen
Weil die Runde geht gar nix
Guck mal hier 11-13 Keg
Ja, ja
Zu Boomer
Geht einfach
Sag mal aber die Runde ist schon
ziemlich krasses ESL Final oder?
Was?
Was ist in der Hinter der Tür los?
Sind die dead?
Ich glaub die sind alle dead.
Nice!
Patrick wieder am Start.
Ja, ich hab gar nicht dran gedacht, dass ja bei euch eigentlich heute gar kein Feiertag ist.
Medic, Oma!
Nice.
Na gut.
So, jetzt hier. Pass auf, High Performance an der letzten Base.
What?
Leute, ich weiß ja nicht mal von wo ich beschossen werde gerade eigentlich.
Oh, das ist gar nichts.
Alter, ich weiß nicht mal von wo ich beschossen werde.
Okay, nice, ein Gegner.
Oh, lege Hänne! Nice, jetzt drehen sie alle um. Jetzt drehen sie alle um, jetzt können wir sie von der Seite bashen.
Oh, ich hör was.
Die rennen jetzt alle hier, guck.
Ha! Bam! Dafür ist die, dafür ist die Pistol Shotgun tatsächlich ganz nice.
Einfach bei eurem Gegner reinspringen und weg Shotgunnen.
Wir haben es gleich, wir haben es gleich. Pass auf, vielleicht kriegen wir das.
Nein, nein, du snipest mich nicht, Kollege. Nein, nein, nein, oh fuck.
Aber das ist gut, die sollen alle, bleibt alle auf der Street hocken, wir haben gleich gewonnen.
Pass auf, eins, zwei, bam, win.
Die haben halt mehr an der Brücke gecampt und versucht uns abzufarmen, anstatt auf ihre M-Comps zu achten.
Hm, hatte die Map eigentlich schon ein Rework? Ich glaub schon.
Ich glaub das war sogar die erste oder die zweite Map, die nen Rework bekommen hat.
Dann frage ich mich gerade, was genau war noch.
Ach ja doch die haben die die haben die haben gut auf auf rush sieht man von dem rework glaube ich gar nicht so viel
Auf conquest haben so viel gemacht da hast du beispielsweise zwischen den zwischen oder oder auch auf auf breakthrough
Dass du zwischen den bases hast du viel mehr cover jetzt mit mit irgendwie so kleinen bergen und sowas
Aber die map ja naja
Ich finde die ist ziemlich top und flop die map mal ist die richtig geil und mal suckt die einfach nur
Das Game lebt noch, naja, Games leben bis die Server abgeschaltet werden, viele Spielen
tun es nicht.
Lasst uns mal kurz reingucken hier, Steam Charts, BRF 2042, heißt übrigens gar nicht
mehr Steam Charts.
Ach, heißt es wieder Steam Charts?
Hä?
Heißt es jetzt durcheinander?
Heißt es jetzt Steam Charts und früher hieß es anders?
Steam Stats hieß das früher, genau, und jetzt heißt es Steam Charts, so rum.
Ja, guck mal, 8.000 Leute, 8.000, 9.000 Leute normalerweise, und jetzt ist es halt wieder mal hochgegangen, weil vorgestern...
Eigentlich gestern, gestern, gestern Morgen, gestern Mittag, genau, bei uns, die neue Season gelauncht ist.
Man muss halt sagen, wirklich viel ist es halt trotzdem nicht.
Ich denke mal, lasst mal kurz gucken, Steam Charts, BF4 und BF4 ist als später gelauncht.
Ja, war sogar so ein olles Game und BF1, BF5, ja, also BF1 und BF5 haben halt mehr kontinuierliche
Spieler als 2042 schon ziemlich pp gar
ach nee lockt in sagen wir könnten jetzt
noch mal die Waffe switchen weil ich
brauche ich brauche ein bisschen an
locks dafür wenn wir fünf an ein dickes
Cheater Problem ok und lasst mich raten
Da ist geht's am Arsch vorbei. Na gut, was ich meine, mal ernsthaft, da musste bei sowas musste halt permanent
Energie reinstecken. Ist ja immer so ein Wettlauf, Cheater und Player und Cheater, Anti-Cheat und sowas
und die haben halt für ein altes Game schlicht und ergreifend keinen Bock. Auf der einen Seite kann ich sagen,
ja, aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht, ich versteh's, aus spielerischer Sicht ist es halt scheiße, ne, sagt mal.
Und das ist eigentlich auch nix, was ich jetzt irgendwie gut heißen möchte.
In die Bobbes geschossen!
Nice!
Ich hatte schon, ich hatte schon die blöde Ver...
Oh fuck!
der dude
diffuse henne
shit
shit shit shit
ich wollte gerade shotgun
aber es war close
da merke ich immer wenn ich eine weile
keine shooters gespielt habe
dass ich in so Situationen wo ich eigentlich
nur grob in die Richtung der Gegner
schießen müsste aber ich kriege es halt von allen Seiten ab
dass ich dann manchmal ein bisschen Panik kriege
nichts hätte. Was eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert ist. Die hier zu hitten ist ja nicht schwer
von der Entfernung. Aber es ist halt. Macht alles die Übung aus. Au. Alles Übungssache.
Alles Übungszahlen.
Okay, der ist auf dem Dach.
Oh, hätte ich den getroffen mit der Shotgun, das wäre nice gewesen, oder?
Aber wir sind schon in ziemlichen ESL-Lobbys gerade unterwegs.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da immer los ist.
Fuck, ich wollte durchs Fenster.
Ah, das geht wieder nicht.
So ich muss mal aufs Dach wieder hoch, wie viel Schuss hat man eigentlich mit der Arme?
Ach man hat nur 3 Schuss!
Ja gut ist ja auch fair, ich mein das ist ne Sidearm Shotgun, ich stelle euch das mal
mit 8 Schuss vor oder so, das wäre schon echt viel zu OP.
Eigentlich ganz gut gebalanced.
Welche GPU hast du?
Ich hab ne Zotac, von Zotac, ne RTX 4090, weil ich zu viel Geld ausgegeben hab für mein
Rechner.
Oh fuck, wäre das geil gewesen, wäre ich da drauf gekommen, wenn ich da alle wegklatschen
können.
Und so haben wir wieder irgendeinen, irgendeinen Typ, oh, oh, oh, oh, rechts, rechts, rechts,
rechts.
In der Hoffnung, ich bin schneller als der.
Ja.
Nice.
So.
Darf ich durchs Fenster?
Nein.
so
darf ich durchs Fenster?
nein
nix da
ah
shit
da hat mich jetzt der Schalldämpfer
gekillt
komm ihr braucht einen Hit auf den Dude
einen Hit Leute
gibt es nicht
kein Hit
in Combat
oh oh shit
schnell darüber. Weil wir haben... Guck mal, die haben noch neun Tickets, die sollten... Ey, please, lass die das jetzt nicht, nicht noch kriegen.
Fuck, das haben sie. Okay, wir müssen auf B. Wir müssen auf B. Das kriegen wir nicht mehr. Das kriegen wir nicht mehr. Hat kein, hat keinen Sinn.
Besser ordentliche Defense nochmal auf B
Ja, ja, ja
Es sind nur noch 7 Tickets, das sollten wir eigentlich ohne Probleme haben
Aber, ihr wisst wie das ist
Umso mehr, umso easier man was hat
Ok, keine Ahnung, ich seh nix
Umso schwerer wird's
Oh, zu viel, viel zu viel, viel zu viel
Ich geh unten rein
Ein, ein Ticket noch. Jawoll, gut.
Geht.
Äh, hast du gerade 300 FPS?
Ja. Ich hab sogar 300 FPS im Windowed-Mode.
Man muss sagen, das geht in diesem Spiel unglaublich schlecht zu recorden.
Im, im Windowed-Mode. Also im alten, auf dem alten Rechner
konnte ich streamen mit, ähm, Game-Capture-Mode.
Allerdings nicht mit Windowed, Windowed-Desktop-Mode.
Allerdings jetzt der Rechner ist fett genug.
Ja, Cheat 95 so ist es. Umso easier man denkt, dass es ist, umso schlechter ist es. Dann
schränkt man sich nicht richtig an, gibt sich keine Mühe beim Zielen, wackelt irgendwie
rum und wenn du denkst, oh jetzt muss man sich aber mal anstrengen und so, dann klappt
es meistens besser. Nichtsdestotrotz ist Battlefield 2042, oder generell Battlefield jetzt nicht
mit anderen Games zu vergleichen, was so die Lernkurve angeht, weil es gibt eigentlich
keine richtige Lernkurve, man muss zielen und schießen, was man wenn man so Games spielt
ja mehr oder weniger kann und man muss sich ein paar Gadgets merken.
Ganz ehrlich, das leerenkurvigste an Battlefield ist eigentlich, so den Fluss von so ner Runde ungefähr so drin haben.
Der Rest ist easy AF.
Collection.
Was ich aber gut finde, immerhin haben die jetzt mittlerweile so viele Maps drin, dass es nicht nach ner Stunde Spielen langweilig ist.
Wie viele Maps haben wir mittlerweile? 10?
Och ne, vielleicht sind wir Attacker Caspian Border, dann denke ich nochmal drüber nach, das zu spielen.
Aber nochmal Defender Caspian Border hab ich keinen Bock.
Das stimmt, jaja, ich rede jetzt nur von Infanterie.
Also Helis und Jets lasse ich mir gefallen, wobei selbst da die ganzen Heli-Pros und Jet-Pros sagen, Battlefield 2042 ist für'n Arsch, was Fahrzeughandling angeht.
Vielleicht ist mittlerweile besser, aber das war mehr oder weniger so die einhellige meinung
Mit oder ohne portal karten ohne ohne also die noch in der normalen in der normalen rotation die karte
Ach, ja, wo ich wollte mir das kort mir hier kommt mal guckt mal leute legacy feature man kann jetzt kurz wechseln
Kommt wir gehen wir gehen das in das morgen dämmerer
Leute, ich möchte ein kleines Backend 14 laufen lassen. Würdet ihr euch hier für ARM oder x86 Variante entscheiden?
Kommt drauf an. Brauchst du eher RAM oder brauchst du eher CPU?
Wobei man sagen muss, die ARM Dinger sind...
Also, kannst du deine Last schön multithreaden? Brauchst du mehr RAM als CPU? Was ist so dein Anwendungsfeld?
In der Regel kann ich sagen, du bekommst bei den Armkisten mehr RAM fürs gleiche Geld.
Mehr CPU, kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, da kommt es ein bisschen drauf an, wie so dein...
Ich, by the way, ich weiß absolut nicht, wie man mit den Dingern schießen muss.
Ähm, wir sind gleich Städte übrigens.
Wie schießt man mit den...
Okay
Wir bunnyhoppen einfach mal rüber und hoffen die hätten uns nicht
What the fuck?
Okay
By the way, ich stelle gerade fest, ich hab nichts ausgerüstet
Ich muss gerade das nochmal... Oh, oh, oh
Wo ist er?
Ist er aufm Dach?
Ha ha!
Lul!
Oh oh, der weiß, dass ich hier drinne bin.
Der schießt gleich die Wand kaputt.
Nice.
Au!
Sag mal, ich...
Ich würde gerne mal reloaden.
Wenn das, wenn das erlaubt ist.
So.
So zur Abwechslung mal.
Okay, Reload.
Okay, jetzt können wir pushen, glaube ich.
Push the Reno.
Shit, zu wenig Leben, hätte ich auf die Shotgun switchen sollen.
Für Reloads brauchst du noch einen Battle Pass.
Bring die mal nicht auf falsche Ideen.
Wie sind wir denn jetzt alle so schnell verreckt?
Okay, der ist gut, der Toad ist noch im Haus.
Ich, ich camp auch mal ne Runde im Haus.
Oh, oh, oh, der weiß, dass ich da bin.
Oh, shit.
Habe ich den gerätst?
Okay.
Komm, Leute, lege Hände drauf.
Kommt, Leute, Legehenne-Time!
Wo ist mein Smoke-Launcher?
Jawoll, da ist er.
Oh, schön!
Guck mal, synchrone Legehenne.
Ich glaube, wir müssen auf A bleiben.
Ich glaube, auf A geht mehr ab.
Vermutlich.
Oder auch nicht.
Die Fuske.
Keiner? Keiner? Keiner?
Keiner? Keiner?
Okay, nice
Ja, nice!
Kein Bock auf die Fuske
Hatten sie da
Oh, was ist denn das da?
Äh
Hä?
Hä? Bin ich blind? War da nicht grad ein Ge- Ach das war ein Panzer den ich da gesehen hab!
Ups!
Wenn es dann liegt, Grafikmod- Wisst ihr was?
Change my mind, aber...
...mir hat die Map auch grafisch besser gefallen in Battlefield 3.
Und das ist wie alt? 13 Jahre oder so?
Oh oh.
Oh, oh, oh! Panzer!
Das war zu viel Movement für den MG-Typ im Panzer.
Richtige Bro-Moves, ja.
Kommt man hier drüber?
Übrigens, war das Battlefield 1, wo man noch über solche Mauern sich drüber ziehen konnte?
Glaube, glaube ja, ne?
Oder Battlefield 5 auch noch? Haben sich gedacht in 2042, nope.
Das ist zu, zu Legacy. Das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Wo sind die eigentlich alle gerade?
Au!
In meinem Ass sind die gerade.
Oh, das sind richtige Objective-Players hier vorne.
Guck mal!
Medic, Recon, Spawnbeacon.
3D-Spotting ist schon ziemlich OP
Weil der Typ hat halt absolut null Chance da irgendwie rauszukommen, wenn ich...
Also, sei da hinter nem Felsen zu sitzen
Wie, der ist nicht down und ich fliege jetzt in die Luft vom Panzer.
Ich hab Schiss, dahinten kommt was
Okay, ich muss weg
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Achtung, pushen!
Shit, dachte...
...dachte er lebt noch
Ist der Dead Guy aufm Dach?
Wie komm ich denn hier wieder raus, Leute?
Komm ich hier raus?
What?
Oh oh, oh oh
Ich hab Schiss
Hier sind 30.000 Gegner gerade
Charlie Mike
Oh yeah, Transport Location
Krieg ich, krieg ich vielleicht ein bisschen Muni?
Wobei, geht eigentlich, geht eigentlich
Jetzt wird geruscht, Leute
Hardcore geruscht
Und am Wasser hängen geblieben wird
Ich bin, meine Map-Kenntnis verlässt mich gerade.
Welche Seite ist das mit dem Zaun und der Lagerhalle?
Links, oder?
Vor allem, wie weit links?
Weiß ich nicht mehr, ist zu lange her.
Guck mal hier, buy more cases, geht richtig ab.
Ich hab Wunder, ich will immer um die Schüsse nicht ankommen.
Ich bin komplett gerade in die in die Granaten gerannt
Okay, wir müssen irgendwie aufs Dach Dach, Dachke, Dachke OP
Ja, nice Wer das Dach hat gewinnt einfach
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ist gut, ich hab dich.
Nice.
Oh.
Jetzt haben sie ihr Sniper-Tooths.
Aber wie das so immer ist in Rush, au, wow, wow, wow, je mehr Snipers, umso wahrscheinlicher
der Loose.
Wow!
Instant weggedrückt.
Die haben das ja auch gepatcht, also diese Season haben die ja nur, und das habe ich
auch gleich als das gesehen hat, dachte ich mir, okay das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst,
sie haben nur die Sturmgewehre angepasst, sonst, sonst nichts witzigerweise, sehr pp-iger.
Okay, wir müssen.
Oh shit, die haben Legehennen gemacht.
Okay, Legehennen!
Ich probier's, ich probier's.
Please!
Prager!
Präge, Präge succesfull
Succesfully Prayed
Alter wo stellst du die denn alle?
Oh ne die haben wieder Legehände gemacht
Komm, wir haben's!
In the bobbas!
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir die von oben.
Nichts zu sehen, nichts zu sehen.
Oh, die sterben ziemlich, da muss ich, glaube ich, unten rein.
War klar, dass er hier ist, ich meine, irgendwo muss er ja hin sein.
Okay, okay, Diffuse Kill, Diffuse Kill.
Alter das ist, das ist wieder krasse ESL Finals man
Breaker, Breaker, Breaker, Breaker, NEIN, NEIN
Und meine Teammates haben Schiss das zu defusen
Defuske Leute, defuske
Boah, ESL Finals Leute
Übelst anstrengende letzten zwei Minuten!
Was, eigentlich wäre das, Cheat95 meint, eigentlich wäre das ein witziger Move von EA, wenn das
nächste Battlefield erst 2042 rauskommt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, wollt ich grad sagen, dafür sind die viel zu geil auf unser Geld.
Titanfall 3, das wäre echt geil, ja. Aber das ist, glaube ich, gestorben zugunsten von Apex.
SgtSilver, du hast anscheinend keinen Feiertag heute, oder?
Was ist denn der Modus, in dem man am meisten Punkte für den Battle Pass macht?
Ich würde gerne mal die Keg W46 ausprobieren, aber da braucht man Battle Pass Level 26,
man.
Was ist denn Holosight für eine Shotgun-Pistole?
Was ist denn mit euch verkehrt?
Conquest? Oh ne, Conquest mag ich nicht.
Dann spiele ich, dann spiele ich, da gehe ich auf jeden Fall mit Boost-Server in Portal lieber.
Dabei sind Apex und Titanfall nicht wirklich vergleichbar.
Naja, das sind aber die gleichen Leute, die das entwickeln.
Allein schon deswegen ist zugunsten Apex Titanfall 3 erstmal gestorben.
Es sei denn, die wollen halt ein neues Team gründen für Titanfall 3 oder Leute
von Apex abziehen dafür, aber das glaube ich nicht, dass sie das machen werden.
Hast du Battle Pass gekauft? Nee.
Ich würde im Leben kein Battle Pass kaufen.
Prager.
Kein Geld.
Da gibt es kein Geld von mir für das Game mehr.
Oder kann man sich irgendwie Battle Pass boosten mit diesen 500 Battlefield
Points kaufen, weil die brauche ich eh nicht.
Was macht man eigentlich mit diesen komischen... äh, ist zu spät.
Erika Harbor
in Chile oder wie die Amis sagen, Chili.
Erika Harbor funktioniert auch nur sehr begrenzt in Battlefield 2042, aber es freut mich immer die Oldschool Maps zu sehen.
Bleib schlau und bleib lebendig.
Rotation
Ja
Ich springe hier mal ab
Gott, schauen wir mal was hier so kommt, ein Panzer, Pantsman, oh Gott wie pp gart er,
ey ich hab nur einen gekillt, ich hatte so eine geile Position alter, so eine Pogposition
Und hab's verkackt
Oh nice, noch einer, gg
Du solltest besser nicht nachladen, ne?
Okay, nice, dankeschön
Der hat ernsthaft eine Claymore dahinter gestellt, ne?
Oh oh, der Tank Oh, der Pants Man
Panzer! Gehst du weg? Panzer! Panzer! Verpiss dich!
Wisst ihr, es wäre mega, wenn die einfach nur komplett, komplett braindead in die normale Rotation noch die Rushmaps von Battlefield 3 reinhauen würden.
So was wie Damavent Peak zum Beispiel oder meinetwegen auch Firestorm oder Grand Bazaar
und sowas.
Dann hätten wir wenigstens ein paar gescheite Maps einfach hier.
Ey das kannst du vergessen Kollege.
Da hast du dir, das hast du dir so gedacht ne, das hast du dir so gedacht.
Okay, easy.
Komm mal, schon 30 Tickets weg, wir haben gleich gewonnen.
Gleich, in Anführungszeichen.
Jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo die meisten liefen immer bei Erika Haber.
Wenn die ersten zwei Wellen-Attacks nicht geklappt haben und sie das neu aufbauen, müssen die meisten Rage quitten jetzt.
jetzt
oder versuchen sinnlose wäre irgendwie irgendwie russien mit
dm bagi rein und versuchen alles zu killen
euch sehe ich muss da du
ich hab jetzt
tops gelohnt war
Hör mal auch so rum zu flitzen. Anzeige. Direkt.
Attacker of Arica Harbor ist so shit, sagt der Chat.
In 2042 gebe ich dir recht,
aber in Battlefield...
Battlefield... also in Bad Company 2
konntest du
A.
Immer einnehmen,
Indem du die Pfeiler von dem Gebäude mit dem Panzer kaputt geschossen hast und dann konntest du dich auf B konzentrieren. Also es war auch schon kacke, ja?
Also ziemlich imbalanced
Aber es ging noch. Ich habe nichts gegen den Panzer. Ich klaue denen jetzt den Panzer. Oh ne, shit.
Kommen sie einfach zu dritt rein
Da jumpen sie
Ok das, nice, nice
Die sehen ihn nicht, die sehen ihn nicht
Oh ne die sind auch an B, fuck, was ist da los
Hört mal auf
Ah ok
Die sind ja frech
Die legen einfach beides
So
Das ist aber nicht nett
Ist kein Daumen hoch.
Was ist denn hier los?
Okay, YOLO, YOLO, YOLO.
Oh, hier ist ja alles kaputt schon.
Hm. Oh, oh, da drüben, da drüben.
Rusht, rusht was.
Wo sind sie?
Dead, oder?
Vermutlich, vermutlich der.
Bleiben wir mal hier stehen.
Also meistens, meistens
haben die Attacker spätestens jetzt keinen Bock mehr.
Es ist vermutlich, ja guck mal
die stehen schon nur noch mit den Tanks in der Base.
Easy. Und snipen.
Snipen und Tanks in der Base stehen.
Da weißt du Bescheid. Da weißt du,
dass du gewonnen hast.
Soundrifles sind echt komisch jetzt.
Aber dann weißt du, dass du eigentlich gewonnen hast.
Oder? Oder? Oder? Oder?
Kann ich den wiederbeleben?
Nein!
Ich will nicht seine hässliche Waffe haben.
Wow! Die Schneiders!
Oh ne.
Die legen ich gehe doch mal rüber. Ich habe meine ich traue meinem team nicht dass sie das hinbekommen
Ich ich die fände einfach bis vorbei ist zwei tickets noch das sollten wir eigentlich locker haben
Hold tight wir halten wir holen zeit leute ich hoffe ich hoffe ihr holtet auch zeit
Ja, Eureka Harbor funktioniert nicht so richtig gut in 2043, also in BC2 war es schon schwierig,
wobei, also ich überlege gerade, was ist meine Lieblings-BC2-Map gewesen, weil Paraise ist
auf jeden Fall vorne mit dabei, finde ich mega nice, aber Port Walders, Port Walders,
doch die Schneemap, erinnert sich noch einer dran mit der Pipeline an der Seite, Port Walders
war glaube ich meine Lieblings Rush Map in Bad Company 2. Wobei die eigentlich alle
mehr oder weniger geil waren. Die Bad Company 1 Maps waren auch ziemlich nice. Die Battlefield
3 Rush Maps waren auch gut. Wobei ich sagen muss die BC1 und BC2 Maps waren halt noch
geschliffener für Rush. Aber BF3 ging auch klar für Rush. BF4 waren die Rush Maps schon
nicht mehr gut. Danach gab es glaube ich keinen Rush mehr. Doch Battlefield 1 hatte noch Rush,
Aber die Maps haben richtig gesuckt
Aber nicht eben schon mal bei 10?
Moin Adi
So wie funsten das jetzt mit dem Battle Pass?
Bei Premium?
Ne ne bestimmt nicht
Kann ich mir was kann ich mit
Money fest nice die hatten wir heute noch nicht das ist auch so eine hit top top und flop map in rush
Kann richtig geil sein kann aber auch einfach nur satten
Und wir nehmen anstatt der messer tatsächlich wieder granaten mit
Was kann man denn für eine Auswahl? Smoke Launcher, Armor Plate brauchen wir nicht.
Oder C5. Ne, wir lassen den Smoke Launcher. Smoke ist geil. Und Attacker.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, am Anfang, als Rush neu war, in 2042, dass man nach ner Runde nicht die Seite geswitched hat?
Oder die Seiten immer gleich geblieben sind? Also warst du einmal Attacker, warst du immer Attacker und sowas.
So richtig Banane alles.
Wo ich mir so denke, probiert ihr das im Vorfeld nicht aus, bevor ihr das ins Game packt?
Und die Antwort ist, nö.
Sie probieren es nicht aus, anders kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Die machen das...
Chat, ich glaube DICE hat meinen Stream consulted, wenn es um Softwareentwicklung geht.
Die haben sich einfach gedacht, wenn man keine Fehler macht...
Wow! Wenn man keine Fehler macht, dann braucht man auch keine Tests.
nur mit dem unterschied dass sie ganz viele fehler gemacht haben und nicht
getestet
so geht das nicht
also dass das geht nur wenn du halt auch
ja immer perfekt programmiert ist
so wie wir im stream immer
obviously
Duuude!
Ich würde gerne aufs Ding oben drauf hier rein.
Wow, wow, wow.
Es ist immer den, den man nicht sieht.
Immer den, den man nicht sieht.
Aufschwingen der Puppe ist bisschen vor
Ich glaub den hier haben wir
Der Pepega1 setzt wieder ein
Oh shit
Ich renn einfach mal weiter
Ich flank die
Ich muss noch was anderes spielen.
Chat, Waffenvorschläge?
Irgendwas anderes.
Ich hab die zu lange gespielt heute.
Kein Bock mehr.
Komm, wir spielen die neue.
Nee, keine Single-Schuss-Craftinger.
Und auch kein Schneiber-Zeug.
Wir spielen die neue.
Schneiderzeug. Wir spielen die angeblich OP-Waffe mal ein bisschen frei.
Ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht, die OP ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig erkannt, was aber auch an meinem Visier und dem 20-Schuss-Magazin
wahrscheinlich liegt.
Ich traue mich da gerade nicht so richtig lang.
Ich traue mich hier gerade nicht so richtig hin.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall mal hier oben rauf.
Wo ist er?
Wo ist der Dude?
Hier.
Aber weit können die ja nicht sein.
Wuhu!
Ah shit nicht, er erwischt Ohhhh, angestelft von der Seite hat er sich
Okay, es ist die Runde Botten ist die Waffe frei, ich hab die schon anlockt mit botten
Ich will euch nicht eine Runde noch eine Runde Bots zumuten.
ESL Skills werden rausgeholt hier.
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, wie viel besser das wieder geht, wenn man das Game einfach
mal 2 Stunden gespielt hat.
Das macht halt schon was aus, 6 Monate kein Battlefield.
Kann der mal sterben?
Also als kleinen Tipp Leute, falls ihr auch mal mit der neuen Season spielen wollt, wenn
ihr Assault Rifles spielt, au, wenn ihr Assault Rifles spielt, ihr müsst die Assault Rifles
tappen.
Du triffst über Range, du triffst nichts mehr, wenn du schießt. Also wenn du ohne zu tappen schießt.
Wo ist der Unterschied zwischen Rush und Durchbruch?
Rush gibt es 128 Spieler, Durchbruch gibt es 128 Spieler, Rush nicht.
Die Breakthrough-Geschichten sind, wir stehen sinnlos rum und Rush ist halt liegen vor der Bombe.
Guck mal, wie du nix triffst, wenn du dauernd Feuer machst.
Er ist gar nicht mehr da.
Und Rush ist halt einfach ein geiler Modus und breaks du nicht.
Warum spielst du das Game noch, weil ich es gekauft habe und es eine neue Season gibt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir einen nice Flank.
Alter, wie man mit diesen scheiß Waffen nix mehr hittet und jetzt weiß er, dass ich da bin.
Okay, der wirft auf jeden Fall jetzt eine Granate hoch, da muss ich weg.
Poggers Flank.
Nix mehr da, wo sind sie denn?
Okay, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen, die wissen, dass ich da bin.
What?
Was zum Teufel ist dieses Ding?
Das hat mich schon total aufge...
Ist das der Airburst?
Ist das dieses Airburst-Ding?
Das hat mich schon so oft gekillt heute.
Ist das ist das der Airburst Campbell? SPH Explosive?
Ah wir haben es, nice! GG Girl!
Ist er ein Granatwerfer? Ja ist, ist das dieser Airburst? Ah ne, das ist nicht der, nicht der, nicht der exclusive Airburst für den neuen, äh, für den vorletzten Specialist da, ne?
Was anderes, anscheinend.
Ah, dead.
Musste für, ja, mal gucken.
Was das für einer ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist der auch gar nicht so geil.
Sondern, ich denke nur, dass das Ding was taugt, weil es mich ja irgendwie schon fünfmal gekillt hat.
Wenn man es dann selbst spielt, ist es meistens ja eh nicht so geil.
Nice, wir sind schon durch.
Shit, okay das war blöd hier vorzuraschen. Hätte ich eigentlich denken können. Vielleicht kriege ich ja einen Revive, wobei es- Ja, ja, ja, mach den Dead, mach den Dead. Und jetzt, und jetzt Revive, gell?
Excellent. Oh shit, von der Seite, von- Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oh oh oh oh
Schon wieder das Ding
Ist aber
Ist das sowas wie die
Explosiv-Armprost aus Black Ops 1?
Mit
Mit so nem Sticky-Ding
mit mit mit so einem sticky ding
ok ich sehe keine enemies
Kannst ja mal komplett knicken hier.
Wo müssen wir überhaupt hin?
A zu A.
Sind nicht viele da, ne?
Geh mal aufs Dach.
Dach, gell?
Okay, kein Dachstelz, nur zu treffen.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da anders hitten soll, aber gut.
Der, der ja auch nicht.
Nice PP Guard.
Lass mich bloß in Ruhe hier.
Aber wir sollten es haben.
Ich denke, ich denke, wir haben es, M-Com.
Ja, nice.
Wie, hä?
Hä?
Das ist jetzt auch die letzte Base?
Mein...
Man musste doch da sonst immer auf den Berg oben drauf.
Haben die einfach die letzten Bases von Rush gestrichen auf manchen Maps?
Die letzte Base war doch immer in dieser Station oben auf dem Berg.
Oder bringe ich jetzt Rush und Breakthrough durcheinander?
Nee.
Reworked.
Ich fand das eigentlich, ich fand das eigentlich besser, als es noch auf, auf den Berg oben
ging.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich so ein großer Fan von diesem Reworked bin.
Das ist ein bisschen kurz, 4 Bases.
So, was kann man denn jetzt mit diesem komischen...
Was macht man mit diesen Battlefield Points?
Ich bin da richtig kacknubig.
Wie macht man da was? Battle Pass? Store?
Ah ja, im Store kann man sich so Dinger kaufen.
Gibt es da auch upgrade to premium battle pass
Nope, machen wir nicht
Garantiert no pass und wie bekommt man diese battlefield points wahrscheinlich nicht durch spielen sondern nur durch
Reinkaschen
Kaufe ich nicht
Mache ich nicht können sie komplett knicken. Ich habe kein weiteres geld mehr für das game aus
Ja bist du aber ich auch scharf
So jetzt mal andere waffe hier
Das teil mal ein bisschen anlocken
Attacker, jawoll. Wir haben halt dafür nur das Kack-Visier und nur das Kack-Magazin und das Kack-Visier haben wir dafür.
Ja, also es gibt sogar noch Server für Bad Company 2, so 1, 2 Aktive abends.
abends
und
wenn sie drei gibt es gibt es eigentlich ein das ist vier zwanzig sieben
bärnert der mal wenn peak
den gibt es
bin ich persönlich jetzt aber nicht so geil und wenn du glück hast am
wochenende mal so vier fünf server insgesamt
das ist auch neu oder
ja das ist auch komplett
Reworket!
Also das letzte Mal, als ich Battlefield 3 gespielt habe, war eigentlich dieser 24-7
Damavent Peak-Server
immer besetzt
wobei ich den halt nicht gut fand. Aber immerhin, man konnte zumindest
spielen, ne?
War nicht normalerweise, dass da drüben...
Ja, Bad Company 3 wird es nicht geben, weil Dice ja gesagt hat, oh nein, wir haben vergessen, wie Bad Company überhaupt funktioniert hat.
Wir verstehen unser eigenes Game nicht mehr, deswegen können wir keinen dritten Teil machen.
Wo ich mir halt überlege, so, naja...
Die Waffe suckt mit dem, mit so wenig Schuss.
Wo ich mir halt denke, okay, dann spielt halt vielleicht mal euer eigenes Game ein paar Runde
Und guckt euch an was gut ist. Aber ich glaube im Jahr 2023 ist es halt für Spieleentwickler von Triple-A-Titeln nicht mehr
Gehört nicht mehr zur agilen Arbeitsmethode dabei seine eigenen
Seinen eigenen Krempel zu spielen
Die sind zu agil und mit Sheeran-Tickets und Daily Scrum beschäftigt anstatt ihr eigenes Game zu spielen
Sollte man jetzt eigentlich auf die Dächer, ohne bei Kate zu sein?
Ne.
Oh, da war noch mehr.
Ich würde gerne hoch aufs Dach. Dankeschön, war gut.
Oh, da war noch mehr, ich hab's genau gesehen.
Hier.
Die Waffe hat viel zu kleines Magazin.
Okay, ich weiß nicht von wo, aber...
Von wo?
Ach da!
Okay, PP-Guard.
Kommst du her?
Ach, der ist dead?
Lol.
War da einer?
Leute, war da einer?
Da war... bin ich...
Bin ich.
War da nicht einer grad?
Ja.
An die Map muss ich mich noch gewöhnen, die ist auch komplett neu für mich.
Ich hab den Rework nicht gespielt.
Wann kam denn der Rework? Kam der Season 4?
Leute, weil Season 4 konnte ich nicht spielen. In Season 4 ist mein Spiel nicht gestartet.
Sie ist ein 4, konnte ich nicht spielen.
Du bist der einzige in meinem Twitch, der nicht Diablo zockt.
Ich habe es mir noch nicht mal gekauft.
Für das, dass ich meine halbe Jugend in Diablo 2 gesteckt habe, ist das schon wenig.
Aber ich war sehr enttäuscht von Diablo 3 und Blizzard hat mich auch die letzten Jahre über immer abgefuckt.
Deswegen weiß ich immer noch nicht, ob ich es kaufen soll. Also ich glaube, ich werde das so machen. Ich kaufe mir Diablo 4.
Au. Ich kaufe mir Diablo 4, wenn ich mir ein Review angeguckt habe oder wenn ich zufälligerweise ein Review finde von irgendwelchen
YouTubern, Streamern, sonst wie, von denen ich weiß, dass die, ja, keine Ahnung, wissen, wovon sie reden, was Action-RPGs angeht.
Und wenn die sagen, das hat Langzeitmotivation, dann hol ich's vielleicht noch.
Äh, what?
What? Was ist mit meinem Enterhaken los? Ist der irgendwie broken?
Path of Exile, größer Diablo. Ja.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dass das nach wie vor gilt.
Und auch mit Diablo 4.
Diablo 4 ist wahrscheinlich das casual freundlichere Game, fuck geht alter ich kann nicht reden und spielen, ähm Diablo 4 ist wahrscheinlich das casual freundliche Game, weil man muss ehrlich sagen Path of Exile ist halt echt wir, wenn man da neu einsteigt, schön jetzt sind wir aneinander vorbeigesprungen
Ich dachte, man kann die Typen auch rausschießen.
Nee, nee, mich kriegst du nicht, Heli-Stelzer, das kannst du vergessen.
So, darf man noch, darf man noch in die Mitte hoch?
Ach da ist schon alles drauf drauf mit
Da ist schon alles drauf voll mit Schneiber-Dudes
Oh, ich bin zu tief!
Wo geh ich denn hin? Was mach ich jetzt? Kann man hier aufmachen?
Hier ist alles dicht.
Win! Nice! Zwar nicht so viel krass gerissen die Runde, aber easy win, easy life. Alles gut.
Du spielst gerade ESF 6. Was ist es? Street Fighter?
Wahrscheinlich Street Fighter, ja.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die in Diablo einen langen Contentplan haben.
Weil ich habe gehört, dass man in der Kampagne von Diablo 4 noch nicht mal gegen Diablo fightet.
Ich kenne die Kampagne nicht, deswegen kann ich euch auch nicht spoilern.
Und so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist in Diablo 4 gar keiner der großen Bosse, die man kennt dabei.
Das heißt, die haben ganz viel Expansion-Möglichkeit.
Die können einen Mephisto-DLC machen, einen Diablo-DLC, einen Baal-DLC, einen DLC.
Also, die könnten schon coole Sachen...
coole Sachen. Ah, guck mal, wir haben einen neuen Suppressor. Ist der besser als der andere?
Sekunde. Collection.
Oh, Waldparaiso!
Horgu, endlich! Pass auf und jetzt sack die Runde richtig.
Scheiß Magazin haben wir noch nicht und wir sind auch Attacker, nice, let´s go.
Also ich glaube die haben einen sehr langfristigen Contentplan für Diablo 4, also es könnte
schon cool sein, wenn man immer mal wieder so, keine Ahnung, so im Monat ab und zu immer
mal wieder grinden will. Also bisschen so wie das bei Diablo 3 es hießen zwar. Nur
da ich halt auf Diablo 3 keinen wirklich Bock hatte. So was ist denn besser? Weapon
accuracy, effective range. Der kritisiert das schon ganz gut so.
So, ok, Moment, ich muss mal kurz in Bad Company 2-Mindset umschalten, rechte Seite am Wasser
ist doch das Beste immer gewesen.
Bilde ich mir ein, rechte Seite am Wasser war immer Pog.
Ich...
Es sei denn, dir passiert halt sowas, dass einer mitkriegt, dass du rechte Seite am Wasser rennst.
Dann spawnen wir doch halt mal vorne rein.
Aber wir müssen irgendwie rüberflanken, sonst ist das...
Frontal suckt halt.
Okay.
Alter, der Dude ist immer noch da!
Ja, die Preise im Diablo-Shop hab ich auch nicht so genau gecheckt, warum ich irgendwie...
Ups, was war denn das?
Warum ich irgendwie 27 Euro oder so ausgeben soll für einen komischen Pferdeskin oder so
Jetzt ist ja mal gut, man
Darf ich mal irgendwas killen?
Ne, darf ich nicht. Und jetzt ist die Attack auch durch, also die
Das kriegen die diffused
Was? Echt? Dachte eigentlich
Okay.
Starke Runde.
Ja.
Da sieht man die
15 Jahre Battlefield-Erfahrung
eindeutig.
Absolutes Peak-Battlefield hier.
Okay, jetzt ist er...
Ihr habt grad gedacht, er sitzt wieder da.
Das auf Range ist ziemlich ein Suck.
Das sollten wir haben.
Die kommen nicht hier hin mehr.
Das sei denn die pushen richtig hart durch.
Hä?
Wo seid ihr denn?
Nice! Ein Kill Leute! Easy Win! Jetzt die Runde ist gerettet!
Jetzt geht's los!
Jetzt haben wir sie!
Ich brauche eine Reloadung!
Was denkst du über das Spiel?
I think you should make a public playtest right now and maybe you can release it at the end of the year.
Shit, wenn man mal aimen könnte...
███████ và
SS
Darf ich
aw
Okay, ich check's manchmal nicht, warum das nicht hittet.
17! Was ist mit dem Typ los? Das ist unser Heli-Typ, oder? Nee, das ist der Drohnen-Typ.
Der mit 17 ist der Drohnen-Typ. Also Drohnen auf der Map in 2042. Keine Ahnung, warum das
überhaupt ein Ding ist. Die Dinger fand ich in Bad Company 2 schon ziemlich pp-iger.
Kennt ihr noch die Typen, die immer an der Base gecampt sind, bis die Drohne respawned
ist?
Die die ganze Runde nix gemacht haben im BC2, außer Drohne zu campen.
Einfach 24-7 Drohne campen.
So, das hier ist schutzsicher.
Ja, ja, jeder kennt die noch.
Und die Büsche, die Wände, die Wände sind auch äußerst kugelsicher hier.
Fuck, ich dachte er steht auf, shit.
Da, der nicht gelassen ist, dass er liegen bleibt, na gut, kann ja alles klappen.
Next, wow, au, au, au, au, au, ok, schwimm, schwimm, stellst, schwimm, übrigens in BC2
konnte man im Wasser schießen.
Nur mal angemerkt, glaub ich.
Au.
Komplett kugelsicheres Holz.
Wir brauchen mehr Schuss.
Erschuss
Okay, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo er hin ist
Wo ist der Typ hin gerade?
kann man geht noch das außen rumlaufen hier geht noch so so halbwegs geht das
außen rumlaufen noch
zwar nicht so schön wie in bc2 aber
ähnlich
oh was ist da unter mir
nix
da kommt was
Guck mal, guck mal, wo die jetzt langkommen, ich weiß gar nicht, wo die hier spawnen.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, nice, nice, nice, wo haben wir denn hier Gegner, Star?
Ich hoffe, die sehen mich nicht.
Alter, das ist viel zu wenig Schuss.
Zum Glück sehen die mich hier oben nicht, lol.
Ey ich hab keine Ahnung wie ich die noch hitten muss
Beziehungsweise ich weiß nicht wo ich auf dem, wo ich auf dem A-Cock, yep A-Cock hinzielen
muss
Schade was aus Battlefield geworden ist, ja Chat
Man könnte sagen, schade was aus so dem Default Gaming die letzten Jahre über geworden ist.
Man muss ja schon froh sein, dass Diablo 4 bei einem Vollpreisspiel, alter ist aber gut man, dass Diablo 4 bei einem Vollpreisspiel keine Pay2Win Elemente enthält.
Vielleicht bis keine Pay2Win Elemente enthält oder irgendwelche anderen Must-Have-Sachen
Die dann, wo dann gesagt wird, ja nee, ihr könnt es doch auch alles freispielen
Jetzt regt euch mal nicht so auf, ist doch überhaupt kein Problem, alles freispielbar
Man braucht halt 5000 Stunden, aber es ist alles frei spielbar, ist doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich brauche unbedingt das 30 Schuss Magazin.
Habe ich das vielleicht schon?
Ne.
Da kriege ich Anfälle mit der Waffe, wenn ich das...
Aber ich sollte es nach der Runde haben, denke ich mal.
Und das bessere und das bessere visier
Ja ich weiß es immer nicht muss ich die gegner auf der spitze haben oder muss ich die leicht unter der spitze haben
Ich habe bis heute eycock visiere noch nicht kapiert
Yep yep eycock
Okay, wir rushen einfach mittendurch jetzt, easy.
Okay, jetzt hier durch die Schlucht.
Okay, ist recht.
Oh oh, oh oh.
Yep, yep.
Oh, ich hab Schiss hier rauszugehen, Leute.
den krieg ich nicht
fuck it
boah
ich brauch meinen smoke granatwerfer
ach jetzt ist hier
jetzt ist hier nix mehr
wow
Ich kann ihn nicht holen
Vielleicht jetzt?
Achtung, Achtung, Spritz in den Arsch
Jawoll
Ich bin reingeschoben
Nein, nein, die Diffuse-Gear
Das erlauben die sich das hier einfach zu
Diffusen, Mensch
Ich hab da so ein bisschen Schiss gerade, hier hinter zu laufen.
Guck mal wie viel hier ist, ich muss hier lang.
Ja, ja, ja, easy, easy.
Aber der lebt noch.
Mit der Shotgun, man.
Alter ich krieg...
Was? Oh Shit
Oh Fuck
Wär meine Shotgun ready gewesen
Wär mal meine Shotgun ready gewesen
Alter die hätten auf den Sack gekriegt
Okay
Auf dem Dach sind die
Die sind auf dem Dach
okay auf dem dach sind viele aufpassen dahinten ist irgendein schneider
geht man ich habe zu wenig schuss in dieser waffe den scoreboard legacy
feature nice rätsel
Ich hätte einfach weiter schießen sollen, anstatt auf die Pistole zu switchen.
Okay, wenn ich Glück habe...
Nice.
Oh oh, oh oh, ganz schlechte Idee.
Pega Aim, meine Schuld, kann ja nix für.
Auch, kann ja das Game auch nix für.
Das große Mech, ja, ja, ich gucke, ich gucke.
Ne, wie viel brauch ich denn da noch für?
Noch 6 Kills, ok.
Fuck. Okay, entweder haben wir es jetzt, oder wir kriegen es nicht mehr.
Auf, auf, auf, auf. Drop mich, drop mich. Gutschi-Bass.
What the fuck? Okay, nice.
Haha, geil.
Das hat's gebracht.
Okay, jetzt wird's schwer.
Jetzt, jetzt wird's schwer.
By the way, ich benutze das Ding einfach nur zum Vorfahren.
Ich stelle das dann irgendwo ab, dass der Typ gunnern kann, von da vorne.
Wir fahren jetzt einfach mitten in die Base rein.
So.
Der kann jetzt gunnern.
Oh, nice.
Gunnern mal ne Runde.
What the fuck, Alter!
Da standen grad 20 Gegner!
Please, break it, break it, break it!
Nein!
Vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht krieg ich ja noch
Und wir haben noch 5 Tickets
Entweder wird das jetzt was oder wir sind dead
2, 1, 0, F**k die sind noch rankommen, ok wir haben verloren
Sag mal, war der Typ zu blöd eh zu halten?
Hat der eh nicht gehalten der andere?
Ich glaub der hat eh losgelassen, der Diffuser
Da war niemand mehr von uns
Und wir hatten keine Tickets mehr
Der hat einfach nicht E gedrückt.
Ja, das ist der Drohnencamper-Typ.
Career Best!
Wundert mich.
Auf was auch immer sich Career Best bezieht.
Bestimmt auf die Waffe, oder?
Anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
Weil...
Sooo, continue.
Also bis, Leute, bis 17 Uhr würd ich noch machen, dann reicht's mir für heute, vielleicht
mal gucken, mal gucken.
So, was haben wir denn hier freigeschaltet?
Carbon series, next reward, close, collection, zeig doch mal her.
Haben wir da jetzt irgendwas gescheites, komischer Griff, aim down sight accuracy.
Naja, ist jetzt nicht so als streut das Ding großartig.
Ähm, ich hätte halt gerne das Magazin.
Geben wir noch 5 Kills.
Ne Moment, das hat auch noch 20 Schuss.
Ich brauch noch 40, ich brauch noch 35 Kills.
Für das ordentliche Magazin.
Noch ne, Leute, ne Runde Bots.
5 Minuten Bots haben wir das freigeschaltet, oder 2 Minuten Bots haben wir das freigeschaltet.
Ich hoffe wir sind Attacker.
Orbital Defense mag ich nicht.
Brückentag morgen hast du mitgenommen? Nö.
Wir sind Defends natürlich, was?
Defenders.
Defendige.
Ne, morgen muss ich arbeiten.
Stört mich aber nicht. Freitags ist eh nicht viel los und im Brückentag ist erst recht nichts los.
Also insofern...
...ist es nicht weiter wild. Morgen Homeoffice.
7 Uhr.
15.30 Uhr. 16 Uhr.
Fertig.
Okay, der fährt doch dahin, wo ich hinwollte.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich will hier oben an den Felsen.
Wenn ich Glück habe, bin ich vor den Gegnern da.
Äh, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen.
Gibt es eigentlich keine Proximity-Granaten mehr für Assaults?
nicht ganz sicher von wo ich beschossen werde
der
das
Okay, ich muss sagen, SPP gart sich schon etwas weniger als am Anfang des Streams.
SPP gart Aim nicht mal ganz so krass.
SPP gart Aim zwar immer noch ziemlich, aber nicht mal ganz so heftig wie am Anfang des
Streams.
Ich glaube hier werde ich gleich gesniped, wenn ich weiterlaufe.
Okay, da kommen gerade ziemlich viele.
Vielleicht, habe ich Glück?
Probier es einfach mal!
Nein!
Nicht wirklich gehittet, oder?
Ey ich fass es nicht, der ist da wirklich dran.
Ey ich wusste, dass du da durchgehst, Kollege!
So nicht!
Ey!
Das...
Das Visier macht mich ganz verrückt.
Hallo!
Lul.
Hallo
Lul
Au boah
Ihr Säcke
Best weapon season 5
Chat was sagt ihr
Keine Ahnung
This one is nice
But it's from the last season
But it sucks with a
20 round mag
And the standard
Optics
Die wurden schön geschottet, oder?
Jetzt gibt es, es gibt, mittlerweile gibt es Rush, ja.
Bravo ist neutralized.
Ja, da müssen wir uns jetzt einfach hier rein campen.
Oh shit, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Da müssen wir uns jetzt einfach hier rein campen zu A.
Und wenn ich Glück habe, retzt mich das Soldier hier.
Das wäre extremly pogge.
Macht er aber nicht, der campt sich lieber in den, in den Container.
Er meint jetzt hier auch Containerfield 2042, kann ich nicht verstehen, wie die auch so machen.
Container wieder auf.
So da oben ist, oh shit, alter, wie viel ist denn da los?
Okay, 8 Tickets noch. Wir müssen jetzt aufpassen.
Die werden, oh die pushen, pushen, pushen.
Werdke.
Startet gerade die Rakete?
Kann es sein?
Raketenstelz?
Nice
Puh
Anstrengend
Wir haben glaube ich 3 mal die neue Map gespielt
Chat was denkt ihr von der neuen Map?
von der neuen Map.
Ich find die sehr...
...weiß nicht, so von der Optik her auf Rush so sehr 0815
Schneelandschaft, kaputte Gebäude und halt
ja, keine Züge, äh, keine Container, sondern Züge
oder Zugcontainer, leere Zugwaggons und...
...mh, also macht durchaus
nen ganz okayen Eindruck
die neue Map, ja. Zumindest, zumindest in Rush.
Haben wir was scheiss unlocked für die Waffe?
Ansonsten, tja, das war es ja eigentlich, es gibt glaube ich keinen neuen Specialist
die Season.
High Power Rounds, ok, zeigt mal her, was haben wir denn hier, High Power Rounds, Recoil
Control reload speed rate of fire
Naja, kann man mal equipped lassen, falls man keine muni mehr hat, aber eher nicht
Und die ist eigentlich genau genug, also ich glaube das ist durchaus okay so
Es wird immer noch gestellt. Ja, ich denke noch so eine halbe Stunde oder so. Denke ich mal so ungefähr.
Chat, wie gesagt, morgen, ich vermute wahrscheinlich eher am Samstag, machen wir wieder ein bisschen Progress-Stream.
Wir haben schon lange kein Kacky-Averscript mehr gemacht.
Ich hab Hunger, dabei ist es noch, normalerweise esse ich so irgendwie so 18 Uhr rum.
Dabei ist noch eineinhalb Stunden hin, aber PPoFatTime kommt eigentlich nie früh genug.
Okay, wieder Attacker. Ich glaube, Attacker haben wir die heute noch gar nicht gespielt.
Doch, haben wir. Doch, doch. Oder? Jaja, doch, wir haben die sogar gewonnen. Die Runde hat
Richtig gesagt die letzte Attacker Runde
Aber mein Team hat es gerissen
Doch doch wir haben die schon gespielt
Wir haben die Attacker Runde gespielt
Set Servers? Wirklich? Schon wieder neue?
Das wollte ich mal kurz checken
Die machen wir dann
Also nicht
Show me Set Servers released
Mh
Ne
Die haben wir schon gemacht
Oh, ich hab den Anfang verpasst.
So, wenn wir Glück haben, kann ich rechts irgendwie durch und aufs...
Ja, nice.
By the way, deswegen haben die sich das Team von Need for Speed geholt bei der Entwicklung,
dass sie geile Fahrzeugphysik haben.
Sollte mal erwähnt werden, finde ich.
Wo sind sie denn?
Wo sind, wo, what the, eh?
War
Okay
Oh shit da ist gerade einer gespont mit dem habe ich nicht gerechnet
Die neuen habe ich gemacht die neuen habe ich ich habe schon sette aber alle
Die sind schon nicht mal sette
Okay.
Nice.
Nein, nein, nein. Oh Mann.
Warum sehen die mich hier immer?
Ich bin doch so komplett gesterlt
Gestälzt mit meinem Silencer
Anscheinend nicht gestälzt genug
Hä?
Okay das waren Boomer Augen, aber ich hab den nicht kommen sehen
Der war auf einmal da
Waren das Boomer Augen oder habt ihr den auch nicht gesehen?
Tschädke
Ich hab Angst, ich hab auf die Pistole geswitcht.
Okay, schaun wir mal.
Ach, der lebt gar nicht mehr.
Oh, da hinten schneibert was.
Wenn wir schnell sind, ach guck mal, wir haben sogar schon die Legehände gemacht.
Nice.
Easy
Ohja, wir sind schon durch
Zack
Ah, bumm
Big Shuck
Ah ne, hier gehts ja dann weiter
So, jetzt müssen wir unter die Brücke
Oh shit, hier gehts ja dann weiter, das war sehr ppga von mir
Jetzt können sie nämlich voll in die Seite ballern.
Bleibt mal hinterm Busch.
Busch, Busch-Stelz.
Darf ich, darf ich, dürfen wir please foregame?
Ist das erlaubt?
Nice.
So, jetzt müssen wir unter die Brücke.
Wir rennen einfach, einfach Lebensmüde.
Da ist doch ein Gegner, oder?
Shit, der wusste es.
Ich hab die Kiste auf der Map gesehen
gesehen, dachte mir so, wir sacken gerade richtig rein. Ey ich schieb sie einfach mal auf die
Oh Mann, ich bin besser an Legehänne dran.
70 Meter von meiner Position!
Ich hab's!
Ich höre hier Gegner rumstelzen.
Da war schon der erste!
Und da ist der nächste!
Hier!
Woah!
Weggesniped!
Kriege ich den Reds?
Ohhhh, weggesniped
Krieg ich nen R.E.A.T.S.?
Ich hab released in dem Moment, wo ich gefragt hab, krieg ich nen R.E.A.T.S.?
Bam, release
Was ist da hinten los?
Was ist denn Charlie Mike?
Oscar Mike kenne ich noch aus Call of Duty und sowas.
Oscar Mike is on the move.
Und was ist Charlie Mike?
C-Move?
Yep, Cock Move.
Falls das irgendjemand von euch High IQ Checkern weiß.
Okay, YOLO. Fuck, fuck, fuck. Okay, pass auf.
Ich höre die über mir. Ich leg mich jetzt hin.
Ich mach den krassen Stealth-Move hier.
Ihr wisst nicht, dass ich da bin.
Ihr habt gar keine Ahnung, dass ich da bin.
So, und sobald er defused...
Lul.
Über mir ist einer.
Der hüpft gleich runter. Ne, der ist auf dem Dach.
Oder?
Ach, der ist gar nicht da.
Lul.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, es wird easy win.
Ich habe nachgeguckt oder gibt es zu ihr habt nachgeguckt
Ihr habt nachgeguckt continue mission continue moving ja kann auch sein
Haben wir nicht gerade schon easy win?
Och Ernsthaft?
Kack Noobs
Ich muss mal kurz meine Pistole reloaden.
Fuck, fuck. Hätte ich den dritten erwischt, wär halt schon nice gewesen, ne?
Es waren aber zu viele. Es sind irgendwie sechs Stück gerade.
Puh, über mir, über mir, über mir.
Muss mal kurz reloaden.
Alter, die desarmen die ganze Zeit.
Was ist das hier?
Die sollen mal aufhören,
gescheit zu spielen.
Au.
Hört mal auf, euch Mühe zu geben,
Gegners.
Okay, da müssen wir von oben reinballern,
anders geht das nicht.
Jawoll, jetzt haben sie keine Chance.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, sie ficken uns von der Seite.
Sieht aber...
Hey!
Ist das Hex... ist das die Hexe?
Ist das Hexe?
Die da gerade spielt?
Der Name sieht so ähnlich aus.
Zeig mal!
Ne, ne, ne ist es nicht.
sah nur ähnlich aus. Hätte mich auch gewundert, ich dachte ich spiel kein Battlefield mehr, aber
der Name sah nur so ähnlich aus.
Das war eigentlich eine recht gute Runde zum Schluss hin noch.
Top Rex, so wie das sein muss. Guck mal, 38 Jahre, 38 Kills. Das heißt umso älter, ich...
Ich glaube ihr habt's, ihr habt's alle gesehen, es ist...
Es macht keinen Sinn zu behaupten, ich habe 38 Kills, es waren fast 23.
Das heißt aber auch, umso älter ich werde, umso mehr Kills muss ich machen.
Wer ist Hexe? Ein ziemlich guter Battlefield-Spieler, BF3, BF4, von dem ich schon einige Gameplays benutzt habe.
Hexe Battlefield...
Ja.
Er hier.
Der geht dann richtig ab.
Irgendwie hat mich der Name nur grad ein bisschen dran erinnert.
Der hat irgendeinen anderen, der hat auch irgendeinen Account mit P.
Und irgendwie dachte ich, vielleicht ist er das, aber ist er nicht.
Ach komm, Tactical Muscle Break!
Ach! Nice! Endlich! Collection!
So zu der Linie, Leute.
Insofern, ganz okay.
Wie switcht man den Krempel nochmal?
Das Menü ist immer noch
ziemlich, ziemlich
crap, ne?
30 Kills noch für das ordentliche Visier.
Och.
Und wieder Attacker.
So mag ich das.
Ich hoffe, wurde die schon
Überarbeitet oder kommt die noch? Ich glaub das kommt noch. Die haben nur ein bisschen M-Comps und so umplatziert.
Weil wenn sie schon überarbeitet wurde, dann finde ich die Map trotz Überarbeitung müllig.
Okay, die haben sie überarbeitet. Die Objectives sind jetzt woanders als das letzte Mal. Hier waren sonst die Objectives immer drinnen.
Okay, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Okay, neuer Map, ah shit, PP geaimt, oh oh, ich wusste, dass ich deadge bin.
Aber vielleicht kann ich hier wieder rein spawnen schnell
Ja nice
Mein team geht ab nicht eine nicht eine gute aktion bisher in der runde nicht eine richtige aktion in der runde hier aber trotzdem
easy easy win
Geh mal da oben drauf, da haben wir ein bisschen was zu gucken
Ach, hier sind wir jetzt! Das hat sonst nie jemand benutzt auf der Map, diesen Part in Rush.
Wie hab ich denn den Kill gekriegt, lol?
Ich muss jetzt da oben drauf, um den zu killen. Lass mich da oben drauf.
S
geschudet
ok die Map
finde ich spielt sich jetzt nach diesem
Reap
nach diesem neuen Placement von den
M-Comps tatsächlich ein bisschen angenehmer an
zumindest der Anfang
kann aber auch täuschen, weil wir die so überrannt haben
bis auf Hourglass, echt haben sie es jetzt geschafft
ja
ooooh
Chatky, ist die nur Headshot, One-Shot oder ist die immer One-Shot?
Weil immer One-Shot ist suck
Headshot, One-Shot, Sniper, Bolt-Action ist
Komplett in Ordnung
Was'n das?
Das ist eine C4 Drohne oder?
Ist das eine C4 Drohne?
Die sah so
so fett C4 aus
Oh shit
Okay wenn ich Glück habe
Ach, der Dude ist einfach hier stehen geblieben.
Oah, fuck.
Sniper machen nur One-Shot, äh, ne?
Es gab ne Sniper, die hat One-Shot Body-Shot gemacht, oder One-Shot Upper-Body-Body-Shot
auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß aber nicht mal, welche das war, diese NNT-Irgend-Ebbis.
1 Shot Headshot, 1 Shot Sniper sind gut, 1 Shot Bodyshot Sniper nicht.
Kann man sowas hier machen?
Oh oh, hör auf zu snipen auf mich.
Ach ne, shit, man darf hier gar nicht drauf.
Sehr gut, ich darf mich nicht bewegen, sonst bin ich dead ge.
Tolle Pose hier!
Das ist doch auch ein Bug, oder?
Dass das hier noch offen ist.
Ach jetzt, ne.
Jetzt dürfen wir.
hier noch offen ist. Ach jetzt, ne. Jetzt dürfen wir. Ok, hier ist schon die Legehenne
ab. Ich lege Hände am Start. Sollen wir hier rauf gucken? Ok, lege Hände. Ok, jetzt müssen
Ich will nur mal schauen, dass hier keiner reinkommt. Ich weiß nicht, von wo kommen die hier eigentlich? Von da?
Von da?
Ich kenne, ich kenne den Fluss da.
Von oben?
Von da?
Okay, der geht aber, glaube ich, gerade ran.
Okay, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ab von wo der reingekommen ist.
Aber ist egal, wir haben ihn gekillt. Und jetzt?
Bäm!
Nice!
Legehände, successful!
Uh!
Nein, ihr seht mehr exzellente absolut exzellente
mit Kenntnis
Performance Battlefield
was kommt jetzt als nächstes kommt es ist große Schiff das ist nicht das
Das andere schief, der Chef noch, sind die gleich geblieben?
Und diese Dinger verwirren mich hier in der Luft.
Einfach mal, einfach mal...
Einfach mal random hingeballert.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben...
Nice!
Damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet, hm?
Dass euch der alte Sack wegstellt hier.
Die haben jetzt richtigen Cack Raid gemacht gerade.
Ah, von der anderen Seite.
Huch, wo kommt denn der her?
Äh, alles klar?
Wir sind komplett gewiped.
Da oben ist was!
Das halte ich für ein Gerücht, dass da oben was ist.
Ja, oh shit, da ist ja wirklich was!
Nice, nicer call, nicer call.
Ich hätte nicht mit gerechnet, dass da oben wirklich was drauf liegt.
Habt ihr schon einmal einen guten Ping bekommen in dem Spiel, wo jemand wirklich was sinnvolles
gepingt hat?
Ich nicht bis jetzt.
Das ist Premiere.
Ich habe so selten gute Pings bekommen, dass ich noch niemals mit gerechnet habe, dass
das stimmt.
Okay, okay, ich hau ab.
So, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Okay, mein Squad suckt, ich muss Squads wechseln, wie wechselt man Squads?
Squads, alles, wie?
Alles voll!
Ne, das ist aber doof.
Ich will zu denen, dass ich da spawnen kann.
Ey, alles voll, das ist natürlich doof.
Ja, dann gehen wir bei ihm hier.
Alter, was ist denn hier los? Die sterben ja links und rechts gerade, wir haben kaum noch Tickets.
Jetzt müssen wir echt, müssen wir echt aufpassen.
Ah, es stellt immer einer hinter einem. Es ist immer der Typ...
...immer der Typ, den man nicht sieht, ne? So ist es halt in Battlefield.
Okay, wenn wir schnell sind...
Okay.
Hier ist nix.
Ich warte jetzt einfach hier und wenn die kommen zum Diffusen springe ich runter und bashe die. Das ist der Plan.
Ich bleibe jetzt, ich camp das M-Com jetzt einfach ab.
Ab
Jawohl gleich haben wir es, gleich haben wir es. Alpha ist auch gleich dead.
Jawohl, nice. Ah, jetzt kommt ja noch einer.
Ist gleich viel nicer ohne scheiß mit mehr Schuss drin.
Oh, jetzt wird's hier richtig international hier im Stream.
Chat, nach der Runde ist Schluss.
Wenn ihr noch irgendwelche Fragen habt oder Vorschläge für nächstes Stream, irgendwas
in der richtung dann
fließt los ich guck danach noch mal in der viertelstunde oder so in chat
und ich bin tot ich bin so dead
lass mal was probieren
bunnyhopping
dass es ein bisschen schneller geht
ok ok ok und jetzt hier jetzt hier rauf
hoffentlich ist da oben nicht so viel los
shit ich dachte es ist der gegner
auf der rechten seite
Ja, da machst du nix, wenn da einer mit so ner krassen Sentry rumhockt.
Ich hätte unten warten sollen, dass die Leute rein spawnen können.
Jawohl, jawohl, jawohl. Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee. Please, please, please.
Ja, oh, Spawnbeacon.
Exzellent, Pfeiffetter.
Richtiger Macher hier.
Okay, wir sind...
Summer! What the fuck is...
Diablo 4 Crying, ich hab's mir tatsächlich noch nicht gekauft.
Okay, A ist...
Okay, ich hoffe, die sind jetzt alle dead, gell?
Okay, brauchen wir noch, oh B, B, wo ist denn B überhaupt, äh, wo, wo, wo, wo ist denn
B?
Unter mir?
Warte mal, wo, wo ist B?
Da, da, okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich, wie, äh, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo,
Ich kenne die Map nicht, ich bin zu...
Ist B hier?
Hier ist B, oder?
Alter, bin ich PP-ger, ich habe so keinen Plan von dem Game.
Aber wir haben es. Nice!
Oh!
Oh, gut!
Pogu!
Oh!
Aus ist für heute hier schon Battlefield ist für mich mit 38 ist das schon quasi Arbeitstag vorbei
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr so lange konzentrieren
Chat ich gehe gleich was füttern wir sehen uns spätestens
Samstag, Samstag machen wir ein bisschen Javascript, Poggers, Poggers stream stellt
Sonntag eh zum aufwachen und vielleicht vielleicht noch morgen aber dann Samstag mal gucken
Gucken wir mal. Vielleicht, ich denke mal, sogar morgen schon.
Also Brückentag mäßig bin ich wahrscheinlich nicht so kaputt.
Da ist nicht so viel los.
EA App sign out.
Alles klar.
Biste... Ne, Diablo hab ich nicht gekauft.
Werde ich auch nicht machen.
Also alles klar. Wir sehen uns heute. Bis dahin. Macht's gut.
See you.